[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
a premium membership at chess.com will
help you improve your game with full
access to a powerful set of learning
tools
unlimited tactics let you practice like
a master with more than 50 000 puzzles
to challenge you at every level
our library of interactive chess lessons
created by master coaches will enhance
every aspect of your game
and after each game you play the
computer analysis feature will give you
feedback on every move you played
turning every game into a chance to
learn and that's not all
premium benefits also include unlimited
tournaments video lessons
the opening explorer and much much more
upgrade now to take your game to the
next level
welcome in everybody on this very very
special sunday it is a
mother's day sunday and a happy one we
wish to all mothers of the world
it is also the first ever super final
here in the feederchest.com
online nations cup we're very excited
and as we
get the day rolling here a little bit
early we start things off actually with
a very very special guest
who i'm going to introduce via some
highlights and some of you
may start recognizing him he is a chess
fanatic a professional footballer
first and foremost of course but he is a
chess fanatic
and he is joining grand master robert
hess and i right now the one and only
esteban granero joins us esteban
you are a huge fan of chess and uh
please tell us have you been following
this event and uh if so who were you
rooting for
hello everybody yes i'm a huge
fan of chess
i'm a professional football player but
in
another life i would love to have been a
professional chess player
but i learned how to play when i was old
so i didn't have the chance but
i love watching chess i love playing
chess this is my
[Music]
what i spend most of my free time so
i i'm so happy to to be here with you
and following the
of course the champions if you are
producing that is
very exciting we're very happy to have
you and i mean my first chess question
for you
is the spanish your favorite opening
you know this is too much theoretical so
i try to use
different different variations from e4
so i used to play e45
piece of c4 and now
bishop bishop sephora and try to do
something with
with my this this kind of bns
system with f4 and everything
sometimes when we bring uh professionals
of other of other sports or or different
uh different genres there their level in
shasta's is very
very minor and interested but you're
actually we we looked it up in
preparation for this interview you're
roughly
15 1600 rated fide you you just played
in your the last tournament you played
in was about a year ago or a couple
years ago
you you've been busy yeah i i became a
um affiliate member because i
joined the the league when i was playing
in the basque country
so i had this this chess club just next
to home so i
joined them for the for the league and i
played like a couple of
tournaments but that's all i haven't
played
professionally anymore so i didn't have
the chance to improve my my radio
but you know it's like i play on online
mostly
because i don't have time to do many
other things but
i love playing chess online or
even when i have the chance to go to a
club i'll find someone in the street
playing chess this is something i i
always enjoy
and people love to make comparisons
between you know
sports and chess what do you find if any
is there
some overlap there does chess help you
with your football or vice versa you
know any
insight you have on those topics well i
don't know if chess has helped me
uh it helps me to disconnect from
from football and and so
and yes you can find some similarities
between
uh you know i read some i read someday
this this book is called
football and chess i didn't remember the
i don't remember the
author name but it was very
very interesting because he was trying
to
analyze chess in the way football and
similar advantages like
central central advantage or initiative
or this kind
you know i try to associate these
advantages and disadvantages between
chess and and football and i found this
very interesting
if you're just joining us everyone we
are with esteban grenero professional
footballer
uh formerly of real madrid now with the
marbella football club
uh but telling everyone a little more
about you have a a psychology degree and
you also founded a company
uh surrounding artificial intelligence
which uh
has a lot of goals but right now it's
been it's been doing research in terms
of
uh looking into different era areas to
help fight the pandemic do you mind
telling everybody a little bit about
what your what your company does and and
what their goals are
yes we i have these these partners that
are
two scientists uh spanish scientists of
artificial intelligence
in in the university and then we found
this company and
started doing an analytics with mainly
sports
also industry but trying to
make this predictive and prescriptive
analysis from data
collected in sports in order to
anticipate
and to reduce uncertainty for decisions
and in in sports
and yes when with this pandemic we have
twist a little bit our our resources
in order to try to make predictions
about the
real contagious and evolution of the
virus
here in spain and also in every
autonomous community
so this is something we have made
just to try to help
and we have spent a couple or three
weeks doing this kind of predictions and
hopefully it will help to make better
decisions in the future
it's fantastic and uh and great effort
and
and also fascinating to know about the
original purpose of it too in terms of
the sports analytics
um i wanted to shift gears a little bit
you've uh
you've gotten to know lavon aronian from
from what i understand you actually
invited lavon to come out and uh visit a
game and i know robert asked a similar
question earlier but in meeting a
professional
chess player like lavonne and getting to
know his personality and his approach to
chess there are there
any comparisons you could make to the
world's elite chess players to worlds
elite
football players in terms of their
personality their approach to different
things or
maybe their competitive spirit what
would be your thoughts on that and
getting to know lavon a little bit
yeah i met levon in san sebastian
because he we were kind of neighbors
he has this beautiful house in
in this beautiful town that is uh
sebastian
and yeah we met a couple of times we had
some wine and play some chess
he's so kind and so
has a great spirit and between
professional football players and
professional chess players
i think they have some similarities that
you know any professional
sportsman has that is this
competitive content
competitive spirit and i remember when i
was
playing some chess with him he always
played
the the the best move and
you know it's like i was telling him
that
you know my level is very slow very low
so you need to
but he didn't take it easy on you he
wouldn't take it easy on you
but he he told me he needs to be to
to make the best move because he's on
the table so he needs to do it and this
is something that is in my mind
because it's very important to try to
if you want to be the best you need to
always try to do the best
you know and this is something i found
out with levon that is a fantastic
person and i send him my my
my greetings from from from marbella
well did you also teach him a little bit
of football what are his skills like on
the pitch
no we haven't we haven't played football
but
i know he was trying to prepare
for the candidates and he was going to
our to our club so i also see that
in order to make this physical
conditioning
that is i think very important for the
resistance and
stamina in in chess games so you need to
be fit also to play
chess because you have these five six
hours
games and you need to be focused for six
hours and this is
also about energy and keeping fit is
very important and i i know he was doing
this in
in our club it's amazing
and great stories to be shared here
esteban i can't thank you enough for for
taking the time to join us i
uh just just want to wish you the best
of luck obviously in
all your endeavors not just as a
professional football player but in the
the company that's investing in sports
analytics and hopefully
maybe even making some headway in terms
of things we can do to fight the
pandemic but
on behalf of the team here just want to
thank you so much for being here and
you're invited to
any any other future chess shows maybe
we can maybe we can play some chess
sometimes so
great to get tonight hopefully we will
do it i would love playing chess
and congratulations for the for the
tournament
and i'll be watching from from now to
the to the final i will be
connected watching the the games and
thank you for calling
thank you so much thank you
well that was great catching up with uh
one and only esteban grenero there it's
always interesting robert and again you
and i
obviously we have an opportunity from
time to time to talk with
you know college's stars of other other
non-chess related endeavors right and
sometimes their interest in chess can be
very minor or just for lack of a better
way to put it kind of for show right for
us to bring them on but in this case
with esteban it was like
far from it right obviously a very
interested chess player 15 1600 spend
time with lavon aronian and as he said
in another life
maybe wishes he was a professional chess
player well he has
been able to play in some over
over-the-board tournaments as you know
he clearly has a love for the game he
even
said specific moves his openings right
so it's not just like oh i dabble a
little bit no i've actually done a
little bit of
studying and he's a player of your own
heart danny he said he likes the
aggressive lines with
you know e4 e5 bishop c4 with f4 to
follow so i was really happy to hear
that
and you know just to remind everybody
who you know may not be clear of what's
going on here this is the super final
of the uh fidei chess.com online nations
cup
24 in fact 36 of the best players around
the world competing but we are down to
just two teams team usa
versus team china for well not they say
all the marbles but here it's all the
dollars right
it is and uh it was dramatic yesterday
if you missed it
saturday was the uh the the day for both
rounds nine and ten but on round nine
team europe defeated team usa
leapfrogged them seemed to have
everything in hand for them to be the
ones
here on sunday competing with china and
then the united states
shocked the world they upset china in
the last round to give themselves
another chance at them today and team
europe
fails to to hold their destiny in their
own hands if they beat
team world they still would have been
here but they were unable to do so so
wow it was amazing we're so excited for
today
and uh let's preview exactly what the
super final format is
right because obviously we've we've been
uh seeing a double round robin take
place all week
uh now we are down to the top two
finishing teams as you can see there
that's who's participating the match is
each board playing each other one time
so it comes down to
the drama of one chance one chance for
everything right
the board color is that the top
finishing team from the double round
robin chose their color they have chosen
white on boards one
and three from my understanding and uh
that that will actually give us some
rematches we're going to talk about here
in a second
uh the tie breaker is that the top
finishing team from the double round
robin gets draw odds now obviously we
had wesley so on at the end of the day
and initial comments obviously of a team
usa person he was like wait that's not
fair but of course as we
reminded him and talked about it the
whole thing we've been doing here all
week has
has given an opportunity for every team
to fight to be the top dog
and otherwise what reward would they
have right kind of like the reason you
have a regular season is to have
something that they have a chance to
defend here in the final day and and
robert you made a great comparison this
would be like an olympics where
if a team was trailing by a half a point
to another team they would have to win
the last match right so the usa
is essentially trailing by a half a
point because china has draw odds and
they have to win
yeah that's actually the exact framework
that i was going in with because at
first i was like well draws four games
it doesn't feel right but that's if
you're on equal territory but this isn't
that
china dominated the 10 rounds that we
saw
in the double round robin head to head
format so china deserves
the upper hand as we see the headset
between these two teams
very close affair in both matches two
and a half one and a half in china's
favor
in the round five battle they had and
then in round ten just yesterday
usa when they needed to win they indeed
won that despite
the loss on board one for hikaru
nakamura yeah and karo has been
a rock for team usa it was actually the
first loss he suffered in the entire
event
uh was in that last round of dingley ren
and fortunately for team usa the only la
ce carlo had was in the one match where
i guess it didn't matter
uh because they got the job done now the
thing i think we really have to
highlight about this uh head-to-head
battle they've
they've now seen seen each other twice
in round five and round ten
is that the the pairings were the same
in round five there on board four
between arena crush and hoey fawn we'll
talk about that in a second but the
pairing that
changed that was the same in both is the
one between fabiano caron and wong hao
fabiano
well he dominated that matchup he beat
wong hao with both colors
head to head and as we bring up the
pairings for the super final
that might be why wong hao is sitting
this out uh and and wei yi has stepped
in here for board two
yeah it's it's a tricky question because
on one hand wong hao is super
experienced player
he's in the candace tournament that's
not postponed he's
exceptional but so is wei yi and maybe
you want to bring in that young energy a
player who doesn't have this
you know personal history with fabiano
caruana you look at their
classical head-to-head it's one win one
draw in fabiano's favor but they haven't
played very much
so perhaps you know wong house is like i
can't deal with fabiano right now he's
the number two player in the world for a
reason
so let's start fresh let's put wei in
there and keep yu yang yi
who's been stellar with the exception of
that final round game against wesley so
they get their rematch
and then finally as we look to board
four you put ho yupon back in there to
take on irena crush and remember or you
found beat irina
in round five despite you know the
difference being
torifon had white in that matchup right
well let's let's start running through
these uh these individual matchups here
i guess we'll go in reverse order
starting with board four and then we'll
we'll back our way back up to the top
board
you just highlighted hoey fawn obviously
has a plus record against arena crush uh
maybe in classical not as dominant as
people might think
uh in terms of just having one win to
her credit but in rapid
obviously a couple dubs there and and
obviously we know that because she's
been
a little bit absent from the world of
professional chess
maybe that record is not as has has as
many games as it might otherwise so hoey
fawn certainly a favorite
not taking anything away from irena even
irina herself would say that
and so uh miss crush has has her work
cut out for here on board four
although i will say that arena with the
white pieces that kind of
uh negates some of the advantage that
hooyphone has that the rating
differential is huge
but we saw arena get a good position
against julian june yesterday
in that final round where irena had
white so that offset some of it but
i agree with you danny of course
advantage china on board four
let's go to board three here as you
highlight it you young yi has been
uh in many ways our was our pick for mvp
he's been dominant on board three
uh no other way to put it and his only
loss of the event
came yesterday to wesley so and it's the
reason
that uh that he gets a rematch here so
uh what do you expect to see here do you
expect to see you young ye repeat an
opening and improve upon it
that he did yesterday do you expect him
to go away completely
uh from the uh the berlin that they had
your thoughts on what we're about to see
well fabiano caruana joined us for an
interview yesterday and he said that
yugang is probably just having some fun
because china's already qualified for
the super finals so this
a5 a6 knight b7 stuff that we'll look at
eventually
you know it was kind of offbeat it was
kind of bizarre
but he can do that when you're playing
with house money so
in this matchup i think that china has
to rely on you you need to hold off
wesley so
wesley being the higher rate of the two
in classical chess the stronger of the
two i would say
but you yankee being in great shape
throughout the first eight games he
played
and then yesterday's you know
head-to-head with wesley so clearly
didn't go his way
let's talk about the uh board two
matchup as we said the head-to-head went
a hundred percent fabiano carwana's way
when it came to his battles versus wong
hao
so the man playing in the candidates for
china is
is out he is sitting this one out after
losing
a uh a very very rough game yesterday
very quickly to fabiano caruana
wei yi steps in as you said robert he's
the uh he's the younger competitor
obviously less experience against
fabiano carbona very little actually
in terms of total games there right
there or two total
so your thoughts on what this means does
this actually help china psychologically
or do you feel like it's a
it's a momentum uh shifter for for team
usa to say yeah you know what
we kind of uh we kind of made you change
your lineup there with fabiano's great
chess
well this is the battle that usa has to
win because fabiano caron has the white
pieces
he's the number two rated player in the
world in classical chess he's
unstoppable thus far in the online
nations cup
so this is usa's board like if i am team
usa
i'm hoping that my other three boards
can neutralize and fabiano can win with
the white pieces here because
no player in this event has been able to
take him down wei with the black pieces
that's a less experienced player
it's a lower rated player and it's
fabiano carawana i mean just that's all
you need to say five minute caruana
white pieces i'm taking that every time
well we still need to bring up the
hikara nakamura versus
dingley wren matchup that is the board
one battle
so let's talk about that we've got uh
one loss
for dingley ren versus hikaru nakamura
in classical
uh hikaru leads that head-to-head battle
in rapid
uh though it's uh it's
also hikara also also favoring hikaru so
hikaru
historically has done has done very well
against dingley run
he has but the you know nearest history
closest to us was yesterday's game where
dingley rent beat hikaru nakamura with
the white pieces
so i understand that hikaru on paper
there has the
you know better headset record he is a
bit older i don't know when all of these
games have taken place
but hikar is the better of the two in
rapid chess
even though they're about the same level
when it goes things go online
maybe just my bias here i just think
hikaru nakamura right
online chess hikaru nakamura they're
synonymous in so many ways
but dingley ren if you look at his rapid
rank in the world
it's number three he's actually higher
rated than a car those things fluctuate
so regularly because there aren't that
many tournaments and the k factor is
higher but i would have to give the nod
to kara nakamura
in a match in one game dingley ran with
the white pieces
i'm looking to neutralize because we
only need to tie the match
if i'm team china we don't need to win
the match we need to score two to two
so i'm not taking risks because that's
when karna nakamura pounces and so
with hikaru being generally in quite
good shape he's had a few shaky games
but overall i've liked his form i would
just try to
get a nice stable advantage if i'm
dingley wren
and try to work that one yeah i think
you uh prefaced it well right in a match
hikara would be favored and wrap it in
blitz there
but uh in a single game dingley ring
gets white
uh it's uh that's gonna be an
interesting one but like you said if
ding push is too hard with white
i think like you said team usa probably
would be happy with the draw there if
you consider fabian or karwana getting
white on board too right but if dingley
wren pushes too hard
watch out for nakamura to pounce back so
we've seen it happen before
this this is gonna be this is gonna be
crazy and exciting
and uh before we get set here for the
games to begin we will remind you
that uh something else that's gonna be
crazy and exciting one of the biggest
things we have going on
right after this event is the european
online chess championship the first time
the ecu
has organized such an event obviously
we've been doing everything we can to
to help be the the online platform the
online backbone of that
and uh for those who are interested in
maybe
throwing their throwing their hand in
and trying to win a cash prize you
should consider doing so so
okay well we're going to take a second
here to just again
gather ourselves uh take a deep breath
the super final sunday is about to get
underway you see the pairings
right there we couldn't hype it anymore
because we don't need to
it's going to be epic don't go anywhere
the super final kicks off here in just a
few minutes
when we return
[Music]
so
and we are back here once again with the
feedahs.com online nations cup
it all comes down to this this is the
super final sunday a happy mother's day
and robert you also have uh
some happy wishes to send here yeah well
i want to say happy
mother's day happy birthday happy
mother's day to my mother but also happy
birthday
to patella hari krishna the indian super
grand master who competed in this event
i want to shout out him and give him a
happy birthday wishes i hope you're
doing well
despite your team's absence from the
super file hari is an awesome guy uh
a great person to talk to and and played
some great chess here with some bad luck
he i
in the end i think was the we was the
hate to remind him of this on his
birthday right but he was the only guy
who maybe lost the game because of a
mouse slip but that was just some of the
bad luck into your face but
anyway we love hari and happy birthday
man let's talk a little bit about these
matchups here
uh robert we we saw the pairings listed
in uh
in color order or board order if you
will just a second ago
now we've got everybody up there this is
what it all comes down to team china
their investment they are writing with
the former women's world champion
uh dingley ren only one candidate the
other candidates sitting out
wei yi yu young yi and then you've got
team usa the same team that got them
here by beating china yesterday is in
the lineup
robert give me give me your last second
hype here before the games get going
i really don't know how to evaluate this
matchup and i think it'll be easier once
the games
get underway because you need to get two
and a half points for
team usa and i'm not sure that's
possible once again they did it
yesterday
but history may not repeat itself on
this mother's day
seeing some predictions there usa 3-1 go
china
let us know in chat who you're rooting
for everything you can
let them hear you maybe some of them are
still listening before they are required
to turn off the show
and focus because it is our daily
question uh
and we want you to we want to ask you of
those players
who has been the most valuable player in
the feedahs.com online nations cup and
why
let us know obviously we want to know
who you're rooting for and now we want
to know who has been your mvp
it all comes down to this and uh can't
wait to hear i can't wait to see some
votes on that i think we'll have some
great
social media reasons because i think you
could make an argument obviously for you
young yi what about fabiano caruana one
yesterday right one twice against wong
hell
what about hicaro for his consistency
right you've got
i mean you've got so many options wesley
so i think i think probably if you were
choosing a team usa it would have to be
maybe be car one or nakamura
um but anyway can't wait to hear what
people think
here we go and we have liftoff we do
where to begin i don't know i mean
too exciting look at this game here we
have dingley wren five
five in a car one eye you just said his
name about being mvp hikaru nakamura
about the black pieces and they're
rushing through this italian game h6
played
to take away the g5 square from either
the
dark square bishop or the knight in some
variations if i can put pressure on f7
and a5 so this is a line that we've seen
in car place so many times danny
against uh maxine vashayla grav against
jon napomnishi
and here against digging around for two
days in a row i want to check in on the
game between fabinho caruana and wei yi
because hashtag team scandi lives
right the crowd goes wild nothing like a
rare sighting of a dubious opening at
the high levels
and the reason we don't like it is that
you just saw the queen captured in the
center and then immediately retreated
that's
typically not good you don't want to
waste time like this but black claims i
have a very
solid base to my position where are you
going to attack me i can put a pawn on
e6 i could put upon a c6
sort of shut down the center of the
board and one
other thing to note is that we have um
we do not have a symmetrical pawn
structure
white has a semi-open e file which can
be uh to his advantage here whereas
black's
a semi-open file the d-file that also if
you poke at that d4 pawn
then you'll be happy but white of course
will not allow that to happen so easily
well i could continue to run through the
games individually but why don't we just
take a second
and step back and look at all four at
once right here we have our bird's eye
view as you and i already previewed the
italian there on board one
what a fast i mean look talk about the
prep that those two guys are busting out
right uh hikaru nakamura and dingley ren
uh we have the scandinavian
there uh then of course on board three
what are we looking at there it looks
like a very sharp
version of some sort of nimzo indian or
queen's gambit um
but yeah nimzo and then uh and then
we've got
our second scandinavia that can't be
right i think that's the board two being
shown again on board four so we'll we'll
we'll check in on that here in a second
yeah
no on board four we have a different
game let's let's pull let's go to that
we've got irina crush
and hoey fawn and we'll head over there
so we've got
a this is surprising to see because it
will start with d4 it
ends up being an exchange french and
arena crush if you know her games she is
a d4 player through and through
but this might be team strategy for usa
hold off on the other boards and win
with fabiano carwana that's what i said
if i were team captain that's what my
strategy would be i know it's putting a
lot of pressure
and the entire onus on fabiano but
that's where your biggest advantage is
and so if you're arena crush you are you
know the board where
china has the largest rating
differential hold off ho youfan that's
the most important thing and as you said
why do we think that
that strategy is coming to life on the
board well partly because of the opening
here everybody it was an exchange french
which don't take anything away from the
fact that you can win these positions uh
certainly for both sides but if you were
trying to play a slightly more risk-free
brand of chess
creating a completely symmetrical pawn
structure and developing pieces just
actively logically it's very difficult
for black
to force something dynamic despite maybe
being the stronger player in hoey fawn
without taking big risk right so that's
what you do if you're irena here right
robert you're saying well
if you want to make this thing spicy
eventually you got to do something where
you play for a c5 and we get isolated
queen pawn structures
or you do some of the lines where where
black actually tries to develop the
queen side in a hurry and get castled
over here for an attack
the problem with both of those things is
they're inherently going to
create winning chances for white
organically so it's not even
not even that you're doing something to
take advantage of a mistake by irena
you're
you're playing a risk risky kind of game
um
that you're that you're going into of
your own initiation right
and the key word that you use there is
organically and i really like how you
frame that because
um for the player with the white pieces
you don't have to take a risk you don't
have to
do a pawn storm and weaken your own
kings nothing like that
you just continue developing you castle
you put your pieces on normal squares
for example castle rookie one
things of this nature but i mean for ho
you fun you don't want to just allow
some sort of easy game for arena crush
you know you feel like you are the
strong of the two players
so i need to have some winning chances i
may not play for a win necessarily
but if my team needs me then i will have
to be able to mix it up at some critical
moment so right now she starts with
knight c6
then on g8 can either go to f6 but
likely e7
and once you put your knight on e7 your
bishop on state has some options as well
do you put on g4 and you try to trade on
f5
um there is some flexibility here for
block you don't just have to play
copycat chess
right it's a good point and that's why i
think uh ifon gave pause there because
of the strategy we're sort of
highlighting about irena's approach to
getting something very symmetrical
irena's not trying to just keep this a
really really stagnant pawn structure
knight c6 is already suggesting
let me get some flexibility here and uh
and that's what she's trying to do so
all right well again before we choose
which game to go back to let's head back
to our bird's eye view and take a look
at all four at once
uh now that we've uh we've got them all
going here i
think we obviously have to go check on
board three one it looks like it might
be one of the sharpest ones and it's
it's
it's also the only one we haven't
officially looked at but um as you look
at all four games there let me remind
everybody of course you can head over to
chess.com
the pairings that are going on are right
there on the left side these are each of
the positions chess.com
events chess.com live or just go to
go.chess.com
onc games and you will be taken where
you need to go so
uh robert let's head over here board
three the chest panda
one two three as he's known you young yi
uh i can't stop rhyming
i'm not even trying okay here we go uh
what are your thoughts on this on this
nimzo as i play through the openings
uh well as you see on board three now i
mean this is a very sharp line
generally speaking but it kind of
transitioned to something that doesn't
actually look that sharp so
before c6 white is up a pawn but you are
going to lose the c5 pawn
and so you're like how do i give this
pawn back do i allow a black piece to
capture me
well the issue is blackstone capture
with the knight on c5 which hits the
queen on b3 and the bishop on b4 is
already defended by this knight on d5
which means the knight and a6 can indeed
move
so that is why yujinggi plays c6 to ruin
black's pawn structure but as you see
the game continue here very naturally
bishop d2 to make sure c3 is defended
and
he didn't take on b7 you can sometimes
throw in moves like that
instead what yu gang is focused on is
just making sure his king doesn't get
any danger
and if you do it you know take on b7
this position you already have to watch
out for
eventual captures on c3 rook coming to
c8 or d8
you're allowing black to just get in the
flow and you have
received one pawn for that but look how
quickly black's pieces just
go after white so i like the decision of
course to play bishop to d2
and after you recapture on c6 the
long-term claim danny and i'm sure you
would attest to this as well
is the split pawns on the queen side
should be advantageous for white
yeah and the c6 idea is is something
that um
you see in these openings whenever the
knight is not on it's let's just call it
the most natural square most openings
that
beginner chess players two advanced
players know end up with knights on c6
but
when knights aren't there they're on a6
or they're on d7
this is an idea that if you've never
seen it before you should put it in your
pocket because
i i call back on different openings i
remember one where maurizevich came up
with a really interesting
way to give a pawn sack back and again
it's one of those moves you're playing
uh you're wasting a tempo rather than
waiting for them to take it
in order to break and eventually target
these positional weaknesses so
um you know i think white just has a
small edge here
positionally you have to think that but
also the question is does so have
something
something up his sleeve in terms of not
maybe even exact preparation here robert
but you know maybe he feels like black's
initiative um
in this line is is good enough to hold
in the sense that he can justify and get
enough compensation for the weaknesses
right you hope that the kind of activity
of your pieces
makes up for the structural deficits and
i will say that i like eugene's decision
not to repeat yesterday's line
that symmetrical pawn structure that
wesley so has so much experience in
in fact they were following his own game
against vladislav kovalev from
uh the vikings a tournament back in
january so going into new territory
where white
is slightly better you and i both like
white's position here yeah i think
that's a very good choice by you gengi
but the choice i mean
you know we we looked at it earlier with
team scandi danny i'm looking at this
and i'm just like
is this a good choice against fabiano
caruana because
i'm feeling suspicious about it yeah
we're gonna head over there and look at
the scandinavian now because you said
is it a good choice i don't know we'll
remind everybody we made some fun steam
scandi jokes and that's not what we're
here to talk about but
again the scandinavian is is a risky
opening inherently because of the time
you lose but
it has its positional idea which is i
know i'm losing time i have a purpose
and i want to try to put pressure on
this pawn and those are the natural
things that black is going to try to do
knight to c6 now b6 is played with the
idea that even though you lose a tempo
on d5
the pawn has gone from d4 as a target to
the kingside bishop and the queen
to now being on d5 as a target to the
queen side bishop
uh and uh and the queen but but it'll be
interesting to see what fabian has here
i mean
there's no way to talk about the
scandinavian without us feeling like we
like white can i just say that a little
bit
well i mean the reason why is look white
currently has more space
white is fully developed all four minor
pieces are developed whereas black
bishops on c8 and even though the knight
on a5 is technically developed
we don't really like the knight in that
square because it's not doing anything
if you ever played bishop b7 you have to
look out for b4 trapping the knight on
a5
so be very careful as you try to finish
your development and one more thing
danny that i'll say here
is that pawn on d5 is such a thorn in
black side
and i personally am never sure do you
play a move like
e6 or just sort of opening up more space
help white because if you look at that
queen side pawn structure in particular
the light squares over there can be
invaded by white's pieces
yeah no and uh obviously the the theory
is
still probably being called upon again
if not exact preparation at least the
ideas of the lines they wanted or maybe
or maybe fabiano has already
surprised wei yi a little bit in his
approach to the scandinavian right the
reason why he might have played it
is to try to surprise fabi but he he did
not slow down
he did not miss a step he's played very
quickly because as we get to the live
position we see he's already up
about four minutes on the clock um we
got to give a shout out here to more
than 20 000 of you already with us it's
early in the morning on the west coast
it is mother's day
no matter where you are thanks for
spending part of this day with us the
super final has just gotten underway so
buckle up sit down don't go anywhere and
uh
and stay here to see what happens
between team usa and team china
board one is where we've got to go to
surprise we should
it's where we start where you start a
lot of things we haven't actually talked
that much about this game yet
in fairness all fork boards are going to
be crazy awesome but
um i won't even back up through the
opening yet robert just give us your
thoughts on the current italian we see
on the board this is a very topical
structure let alone opening that we see
at the high levels these days and these
guys clearly bought their brought their
best prep
yeah this is one of those positions
where you say chances for both sides and
it's a cop-out and the reason why you
say that is because if you look at this
position
what are some of the dynamics you notice
i noticed an isolated pawn on a2
but a very strong bishop on b3 aiming at
the black king
and then i look at some of the other
pieces i say wait what's this knight on
h7 doing it came from f6
well if that knight goes to g5 you can
start making inroads against the white
king and not only is it aiming at the
king side
directly the d4 square is essential to
this position because if that pawn ever
pushes
well then that bishop on b3 looks
useless and the bishop on b6 now becomes
the powerful one
so knight to g5 ideas are very common in
these kind of italian positions
and it removes a defender of the center
and there's a bishop on b2 upon on c3 of
rokhandi and i know
for the time being it's defended but
that's one of the ideas not to mention
you can bring
more pieces forward for black
and i love the point you're talking
about knight g5 not just as a means to
okay if a trade happens i bring the
queen over here to the king's side
uh but as you said knight the knight on
f3 is such a key supporter of what white
wants which is to keep this tension
white doesn't want to be the first to
break as you said blocks the bishop
opens up this guy so
so many people actually following this
game directly on chess.com right now of
all the
all the four boards of course akara
nakamura has a huge following online and
the chat room directly on chess.com
forget twitch and youtube and chess tv
which is great
uh you're awesome we love you but that
that i can just see the amount of people
going nuts over there directly on
chess.com it's exciting
so all right um again as we said this is
a very topical opening but if you just
tuned in
these two guys we kind of skipped over
them because they played so fast this
theory was just like
like this is something they might have
you know been bringing to a candidate or
something that neither of them
even paused to think at all until we got
to about right here
uh hikaru took three minutes and 10
seconds you can see the time logs
directly on chess.com which is important
context versus commentators
because what is it suggestive of robert
that means right here on move 13
before rook a8 hikaru was maybe on his
own for the first time
right slowed down he took three minutes
on that move
and started to slow down a little bit
more in each move took about a minute
and a half here
and another couple minutes on this last
move knight to g5 so
your thoughts on the time management as
we see hikaru nakamura on camera robert
and what's that suggestive of
i think he also might be slowing down to
look at his teammates boards and that's
one of the critical things here that's
different from when you just watch
nakamura dominate players like me on the
internet versus a team
event where you say wait a sec let's
let's see how my teammates are we need
two and a half points we can't tie this
match we need two and a half so slowing
down
will help him evaluate do i need to go
for more
or can i play solidly and if you know
dingley run also play
solidly we just have a sort of even type
of game but i don't think this game is
even i like black's position here
i like the car was done too is really
smart and a knight on g3
tends not to be a very good piece when
you can mobilize your pawn structure
as black h5h4 is the type of idea that
comes to mind just kicking that knight
out
from its square and it's not really
risky in the sense that sometimes you
push pawns in front of your king and you
regret it
but here is not one of those examples
and one more thing that i
failed to mention earlier is knight a5
for black if you want just the bishop
pair
you can play knight a5 at some moment
and you called it hashtag
grandmaster robert hess playing guess
the move today but speaking of things
you might want black might want the
bishop here but we're going to go over
to fabinho caruana versus wei yi because
uh
fabiano might want himself a pawn on c7
what has happened here
i was spying that board and i'm
wondering if there's just a free pawn
about to fall okay e6 was chosen you
sort of suggested
that if you don't want a slow
development robert highlighted that b4
might be a problem here everyone because
of the knight losing squares
e6 is the other approach the risk is the
opening of the d
file might have just hung yeah and
fabiano has just stolen a pawn everyone
yeah that's a free one and sometimes
when you trade queens you liquidate you
feel like
even though i've given up a pawn and
more space for my pieces i can
uh hold off my opponent but the key to
something like this is bishop on g7
because that bishop is
lining up against the b2 pawn but now
bishop b5 was played
so what fabiano very smartly is doing
he's saying
play knight c6 move backwards and then i
can move my bishop again
as is needed so i'm dragging your piece
from a potential threatening one into c4
maybe drawing it back to c6 is helpful
for white elisa fabiano carjuan's
opinion and upon is upon here
i don't see an easy way for black to
claim and justify
that i have full compensation i don't
think it's sufficient here i think that
white
surely is better i i agree and i love
your point about just the tempes you can
gain i think sometimes those are the
most instructive points that
uh you let let your opponent make a
threat sometimes because is the night
really better here than it was on a5
blocking the rook maybe with potential
to go into c4
the answer is no and now the bishop
could go to a number of squares you
could you could even relocate it to this
diagonal if you really want
or you can just back up this way or find
another move so
interesting stuff fabiano plays bishop
e5 we also see that he's just playing
quickly and this has been something
we've talked about and applauded him for
the entire event because
along with the kara nakamura he's been
leading team usa uh the most consistent
player
and he's uh he won both games on board
two against china previously against
wong hao and that's why he's probably
playing wei yi
but he's been underrated in terms of his
clock management
consistently up on time against
everybody he's played in this event
and i think he's been unfairly
criticized for many years now about
how he's not the best rapping and blitz
player and all the stuff you know it's
easy to look average when everybody else
around you is extraordinary
and so when he plays in the grand chess
tour is that live
is that my excuse too by the way sorry
go ahead no you need
many more excuses than that but for
fabiano he tends to finish in the middle
of the pack or maybe even
lower in the standings in those type of
events but then you put him on board two
and he just goes to town he crushes
everybody in his path
and unfortunately for wei he's the
newest uh obstacle
in fabinho's way of scoring more points
yeah is this it's what uh what fabi's
been doing on board two and
you and i talked about it very much in
the beginning of this event and then we
you know got distracted with other story
lines those happens but the only things
we talked about putting
nakamura on board one was not an
accident for
uh team usa not just because hicario is
a higher rated rapid player and
very experienced but hicaro tends to be
very resourceful and persevere his
personality is also very pesky i think
for some of the top players but
regardless of his ability to hold what
it did was it put fabiano on board two
where he's been able to score even more
points and i know we want to say every
one of these guys could be aboard two
board one
but it is a little different when you
put arguably the strongest human being
on the planet after magnus carlsen
on board two i think it's been a big
advantage for team usa and we'll see if
it pays off
uh for a car and nakamura it's what you
call taking one for the team right the
car nakamura would score more points
on board too than you would on board one
but that's often the sacrifice you need
to make when you're in a team event is
you need to hold down
that top board carl nakamura's done a
great job of doing just that
and uh well five minute carwana looking
in excellent shape in this position
against huayi
speaking of uh holding it down we go to
board three the uh
three-headed monster that is uh really
foreheaded monster lanier dominguez
perez did not have his best event but
he's also one of the big four here
in the united states these days but
wesley so another guy that could be
aboard one or board two
and he's now aboard three facing off
against yu yong yi uh might have been
exactly what what we
you know we not we but people needed we
asked the daily question what would it
take to slow down china
because yu yong yi has been a wrecking
crew by himself a single man wrecking
crew
but wesley so beat him yesterday and and
now now uh wesley is
well it's a pretty balanced position i
mean one thing we can say is the
structure has changed so that both sides
now have the same weak pawns that's
interesting
uh let's let's see what happened there
the bishop came to d2 and after the
capture
we had a trade on c3 both sides
naturally developing their pieces and uh
here we are in a very very equal looking
middle game well it's interesting you
mentioned the
placement of the pawns i'm thinking
about the placement of the pieces the
bishop on g2
is such a strong bishop right it's
aiming at the pawn on c6 it's on its
best diagonal the bishop on e7
i mean it leaves something to be desired
the knight in a6 the bishop one c i just
think that white's pieces
are better coordinated here which is why
i would say that white is slightly
better ideas like queen e4 come to mind
hitting c6 hitting e5
so black's pawns feel easier to attack
and whites
feel quite safe and so that's why i
would say the white's slightly better
nothing major right
i think black just has a kind of a
critical decision at this moment
of actually what move do you even play
here and and as i look at the position
danny
i'm struggling to come up with the
answer because of um
these pawns being a little bit um
vulnerable but
i mean maybe it's i'm kind of
overreacting just because white is a
little bit ahead in development
and it just feels like more harmonious
piece placement
yeah i uh i i don't have a more logical
move than something like bishop to e6
at least knight to g5 isn't exactly
possible right away
but note that on the last move you young
yi took four minutes
before playing the move queen to c2
these are some of the finer details we
really get to focus on now when we don't
have
12 games going going crazy throughout
the main event right we're looking a
little more about clock management
what that's suggestive of queen to c2 is
a move that takes away the square of f5
for the bishop and gets off the b file
for tempe
but clearly it's throwing wesley off a
little bit he doesn't quite know what he
wants his plan of development to be
yeah i don't think there is a clear plan
necessarily
uh for wesley and that's why quincy is
so nice because it doesn't get blocked
what is your move on bishop e6 for white
on bishop e6 i might play rook to b1
rook fb1 i don't have my a2 pawn oh
actually i'm not hanging it but
just go to the b file okay and you know
maybe we challenge i don't know
somehow being a little equal here yeah i
i'm not saying black's in any sort of
danger necessarily and it's probably
just you know fine in this case but i
will play knight g5
i think i have to right here that's the
thing i wanted to do i really want to
lose the bishop here that's tough right
now black is down the bishop pair
exactly and then my bishop can go e7 to
d6 and
there are some squares that i can take
advantage of but danny
uh he chooses a different move queen c7
and after an extensive think there i
mean
it's a retreating move queen e4 still
comes to mind as a way to hit e5
uh but um then i'm gonna be honestly my
attention has been drawn back to the
ikar nakamura game
because a lot has happened okay well
then let's go there let's back this
thing up we've got the four board view
up as you can see
all four games rolling a quick shout out
go to chess.com and and pull them all up
yourself but as
as uh robert said we're headed back to
board one
transitions are occurring exchanges have
occurred pieces are off the board
uh let's uh let's bring up the focus
there to okay nakamura and dingley wren
ikaro is still in a pretty good spot the
opening of the position
instinctively robert i i can't feel
anything but
black is doing better here than you than
you see in some of these mainline
italians
this looks really good for black you
have control of the a file
you have some potential on the king side
but you know it's not like
white doesn't have plans of his own
because if you allow me to say play c4
and then
start pushing my kingside pawns where i
have an extra pawn on the
e through h files that black king is
kind of all alone there the queen if6 is
doing a good job
but if that bishop gets the full length
of diagonal you can see some problems
not to mention e5 you give white a free
move that's actually a very big threat
in some lines because the d-pawn is
pinned to the bishop and things like
that so
you have to make it work these are just
ideas that are coming to my mind but
i i think that black is better but you
have to tread carefully
because you don't have all day to sit on
the position it's not one of those kind
of advantage i think it's a dynamic
advantage and
i mean bishop c6 sort of comes to mind
just poke at e4
get that bishop off of hanging square um
but
yeah it's a tricky position because even
if you are happy as black we see hikaru
kind of
given pause to think he knows this is a
critical one because you'd love to go in
for lines like this
and and and call e5's bluff and and just
keep playing sharp moves to
to see where it goes but it feels very
scary if white gets e6 that's probably
apparently it's not the problem uh but
it's crazy to think you would go for
some line like this and allow the past
pawn god it feels so dangerous but
it could i mean did you feel the dynamic
pressure that black possesses with the
bishop hair and the second rank control
here
yeah because open files open position
favors bishops
so that's why you know as soon as you
push a pawn you're probably leaving
something behind
and these bishops as you see in the
position we're analyzing looks quite
good but in the live board hikaru
is sitting and thinking here it is a
tough decision do you start with rook a2
to stop c4
do you allow c uh the c4 move and play
rook a2 later
do you move your queen out of the way to
start with can i play queen g5 here
and say you know now i might have some
bishop e3 bishop f4
rerouting this bishop into the position
so black has options here
um so i do really like your car's
position but i think that dingley wren
uh you know he's very capable of just
that counter strike and if you're not
careful
that moment happens and then your
position falls apart
well uh the games have all reached this
sort of critter game
critter game that's a hey criddle game
tm just invented that they've reached
the critter game
let's bring up our four board view of
and uh we've got the middle game jokes
aside
critical positions on all boards and uh
exciting exciting stuff
i you know i think from a match strategy
we we've got the two board ones on
cameras we look at all four boards
it's it's kind of going okay for team
usa in the sense that if everyone else
can at least hold
fabiano car one on board two that's
where they've been getting their dubs
and he's up a pawn against wei yi and uh
and uh
an advantage for white yeah this
you know i'm looking at these boards the
board four
uh not a symmetrical pawn structure
because white is upon g3 but
it's looking pretty level um the fabiano
game he's still up upon have to like his
chances there
board three is we have this you know
bird's eye view
looking nice for you yankee who actually
brought the queen to e4 over c4 and look
at that knight on b8 danny that one from
a6 back to b8
um yeah so i don't know where we should
focus but
head and i think that game is gonna get
our
focus not just because it's the board
one battle two of the biggest stars in
the match but
it looks like it's gonna get real spicy
here but this move bishop a6 was quickly
met by queen to e6
interesting stuff white certainly has a
little bit of an edge but
how does how does black solve the
development problems now that's the
worry is that
uh i can't get my pieces out right now
unless i'm willing to go back to c8 and
kind of repeat
wait did he also just give up the e2
pawn so what's his idea because bishop
takes e2 is a pawn
um is a pawn
what is his idea here there must be
something
like he's just going to rook d2 and say
all right you're actually helping me
double on the d
file uh your knight on b8 rook on eight
still stuck over here
but something
hmm would you take that pawn danny he
did take it
oh he did wow well he's uh he's and rook
d2 was quickly answered so that was the
apparently the answer uh you young e
believing in the compensation here
it's a very very dangerous approach and
you know um
it's it's interesting that black is
black is under pressure here you can
tell white does have pressure just from
the way the engines evaluate this is
still a little bit better for white as
you can see despite the pond sac but
but from a practical point of view you
kind of steal that pawn and ask
questions later right now you're in a
hold mode if you can just
get your pieces developed before
anything bad happens
that pawn might might be everything you
need to draw and the ideas that are
coming to my mind for white well rook 81
and supernatural move here and then
knight h4
just to maybe get my knight into f5 put
pressure on c6
of course rook d7 would be a threat if
you allow me to do that but
i imagine that blackwater played bishop
c8 back and just defend the seventh
but look at what black's doing right you
would bishop c8 to a6 take on e2 back to
a6 back to ca this is well white can
even do this and just to point out
uh the the obvious that if you if you
keep attacking now that white has a huge
edge i just i think at some point maybe
this queen comes over to this side of
the board you still can't develop your
knight because d7 is
is under pressure um i i mean white's
going to have an initiative here so
for sure this is going to be a dangerous
game for wesley so
i agree and um yankee has been playing
exceptionally all tournament and uh he
lost to wesley yesterday so you know on
a personal note danny
he wants to beat wesley well you young e
has been an mvp
for china i mean just remind everybody
he's you young he has been
has been the man despite transmitting
from the same old-school wi-fi that
obi-wan kenobi did
and uh and that hasn't really held his
webcam back at all so
uh no i mean he really has been he's
going to bring the pressure against
wesley but if if i was team usa and i
was relying on a guy to play some
play some defense wesley is super
technical you and i talk about it all
the time he's very
you even hear it in the interviews right
robert yesterday we asked him questions
and you can tell the lack of emotion
that wesley plays with
he just says things offhandedly like i
don't really think about the result at
all in the middle of the game i think it
clouds your vision and prevents you from
being objective
he says things that are it's the way
that i aspire to be and will never be
non-emotional like wesley is just so
technical
so accurate and i think it helps him
defend tough spots
it does and um you know he's in a
knight h4 was played i like that move
it's one of the ideas i don't know the
exact move order which was best but i
was saying rook d1 knight h4 things like
this
we both like yang's position danny i
think we should just maybe
show quickly just the boards in boards
four and two because i do want to go
back
to uh hikaru's game and investingly run
in a second uh but i just want to you
know give
everybody just what's going on on board
four we have a queen
and two minor piece end game between
hoifan and irina and finally at long
last you know how you mentioned c5
so long ago is the one way to mix things
up it finally happens
well the risk for uh hoey fawn is d5
could become weak but now with pieces
off the board i think c5 was
is a sign that black is wants to get at
least a little bit of winning chances
you called it partner you said ifan
needs to at least keep the option of
playing for a win alive depending on
what happens with her teammates
and i think c5 says look i know i'm not
playing for a draw in this game i got to
create something here against irena
and as you said board two fabiano's
still up a pawn uh it is a clear pawn
against hawaii no matter how you look at
it i don't think there's any excuses
there
um but we got to go back to number one
as you said hikaru nakamura
and uh dingley wren because things have
turned around there in the opposite
direction now
for hikaru he brought the rook into a2
just moments ago we're gonna we're gonna
show that right there he brought the
rook into a2
rook e2 was the response and then he
played queen e7
interesting he backs up here comes c4
with the threat of f6
that's the kind of dangerous move that
will blow open your king side so carlo
plays f6 himself
but now the knight comes in to the newly
weakened light square so dingley wren
trying to to work it as they say with no
diggity and uh and he's getting a little
bit of an edge here now
against hicaro for the first time and
look at that he
lifted his rook to d3 because that rook
will likely go over to g3
but don't count blackout so fast because
look at the king on h2 the knight and f4
maybe this bishop on b6 will go to c7
and play deep for d5 because
if you're not tactically alert that
happens and your whole position
collapses because of the knight hanging
in behind it the king
so that's one idea that's coming to mind
is a defensive one for black but let's
say black just plays king to h7
and you know me if you can somehow pile
up pressure on g7 just bring my rook
over to g8
i'm not sure that black's position is so
bad although
you know danny you and i we look at this
we're just like okay white is sort of
playing with a free hand
because you've clamped down uh on all of
the pawn breaks that black typically
relies on
so meaning yeah d5 is off the agenda
b5 is is kind of non-existent right
although that's a long term idea to keep
in mind too right i should mention that
because if this bishop gets out of the
way
whether you get d5 as a knockout punch
or not remember black does have the
bishop pair
which if at some point the light squares
are pried open suddenly i kind of like
that idea as a long-term chance for
black's pieces
yeah the downside of playing b5 is that
it gives white the d5 square so you'll
take once on b5 and try to get d5 but
that is a long term idea
that you know if you could support with
a rook and then play b5 you're opening
up an attack on the b3 square so
um that is something that karu can hope
for but it just feels like now
dingley wren is calling the shot so
earlier icaru
kind of liked his position he controlled
the a file but now the a file is proving
to be meaningless you know
you have a1 under control a2 is nothing
to
write home about so um somehow this has
turned around at least in terms of who
it feels easier to play
with right wow well uh well you know
what's super easy
to do as well whoa whoa whoa knight g6
right away despite allowing d5
that's what i'm looking for but i guess
bishop g6 rook takes g6 is his plan so
wow but you see icaru kind of kind of
zoning in here
that's that's a very focused takara face
there that is uh
zero distractions not one you always see
when he's streaming
looking deep at the position i think if
he just moves the queen
doesn't that pose more problems for
white you put the queen on e8
or even d8 and here comes d5 in a lot of
positions
yeah that looks very scary because d5 is
happening
no matter if it's a pin on the rook or
if the rook just remains there
because there's a you know you have to
move your king out the way and then d5
but maybe d5 is now with e5
and so white actually is inching closer
to that black king
interesting it's this is a really tough
decision danny because
um you know we have an analysis board we
can just make moves and take them back
but if you're anticipating d5 is now
with e5 and your king side is being
blown open
that will cause you serious pause but at
the same time it almost feels like a
no-brainer to not take the knight
because if you take the knight and the
rook comes in
i feel like things are only going to get
more scary for black and
maybe not maybe i guess from a match
strategy point of view he says well if i
can defend that
getting a few more pieces off the board
getting to an end game that might be
hard for black to lose
but i don't think okara wants to defend
that way i think that going to an end
game
anyway doesn't mean no losing chances
especially if you have a bunch of
potential targets on the dark squares
you're parting with your bishop pair
i feel like ricardo's going to want to
keep the ladies on the keep the pieces
on the board here and just move the lady
to safety
yeah um he's the way he's been thinking
i've just seen him
move you know he's he's a lot of
different facial expressions
his head placement is going all over the
place and that said just
he knows that he's aware how quickly oh
there's a you see that
head shake that's icaro nakamura head
shake number six i haven't seen it in
months
he's deep in thought right now he's 20
moves deep he's not even looking at the
chessboard he sees the matrix
code is running hikaru is calculating
deeply here
and also apparently shampooing regularly
very very healthy head
well he is trying to figure this one out
and no queen diet i like your move danny
i think that car ultimately will play it
but he there's something he's uncertain
about and i i really feel like it
revolves
around black playing d5 and he does take
on g6
but you can tell he regretted it he
didn't yeah i don't want to do this
right so maybe he just got a little
nervous about some of the pressure
with the pieces there which is
understandable um obviously
ding recaptures with the rook instantly
whoa d5 check here we go
this is gonna get spicy that is a
surprising move robert because it
what does he see about f6 i'm like
that's the exact opposite move you want
to you want to make because if i move
the king
now d5 and f6 are hanging but what does
black have here
well i guess you know i i just saw the
bar drop i don't know
exactly why but oh i think i think
there's a trick on h2
maybe that's what he wants i i don't i
don't have the moves either oh good no
you got it d4 because you can't take
a double attack
actually go forward just one more move
so bishop before queen d6 you have queen
g1
thinking you're protecting both rook a1
you don't have to ask me twice to
deliver that blow on the board
the queen is overloaded that's how you
get things done
hikaru spies something on the dark
squares here which is why he surprised
us and took g6
with d5 check i think
if i think this could get wild very
quickly you have to play e5 as white
but that's a pawn i want it you can't
take that i know i hate i hate f6 i hate
when you do that
if i take they have f6 everybody that's
robert's idea
man and he car was really he's been
shaking his head
but he's doing it both to give himself
confidence inspire himself
but also he has this like quizzical look
like is this actually going to be good
for me
he's looking at his other boards i
recognize that he's looking at the team
yep so maybe we should do the same while
uh yeah let's rip the bird's eye view
and take a
take a step back as this action
continues to roll here more than
25 almost 26 000 of you with us now
across a ton of different platforms if
you haven't yet hit that follow button
you might be finding chess for the first
time on one of these uh content
consuming
portals as they're that's a fancy word
for things like twitch and youtube
content consuming portal man um hit that
follow button hit that subscribe button
and uh and get more chess so
yeah this game is super exciting we've
still got hikaru and ding on camera the
the yu yong yi games interesting if
wesley is holding that fabiano's the
only person really in control for team
usa
and and if on i think we got to check
back there one more time here let's head
over to iphone's game we haven't looked
at it in a long time
um because even though it's it's not the
most exciting game which is partly why
it has been a little neglected
the structure has changed finely so what
what long-term chances do you really
give black with the imbalance of the
bishop versus the knight
the queen is slightly more active uh for
black
what are your thoughts here for me it's
about the activity of the queen
because i would love to capture on d4
and put my queen on e2 and she does just
that so
i mean she's trying to get active
immediately and if you can tie your
opponent's pieces down and give
no sort of counter play then you can
build on your position so for example
knight takes d4
by white will likely be met by just
knight takes d4 and after cd4 i'm
thinking queen e2 but now i'm noticing
queen f5 for white
you have this typical drawing mechanism
exactly just go on a yoyo string between
c8 and f5
and you're set holding the draw because
there's nothing blocking you to stop
it
yeah you got to do it well i i mean
irena is thinking wait and we have seen
the transition
the trade is on the board so this is
getting closer and closer to what will
have to be seen as a successful result
for team usa i mean arena crush playing
against
the highest rated women's player on the
planet active players as
far as they go the second best of all
time i think behind you to pull guard no
one really denies that at this point
so the draw is is a win for team usa at
least
at least from the perspective of the
match right
i think that white still has something
to prove just because black's queen
is better placed look at the queen of b5
attacking b2 the queen on b1 protecting
so you just hear those
verbs there black is the more aggressive
player right now
but it is there's so few pieces
remaining that it feels like
irena's chances are good to hold and
she's doing well in the clock
and you know we have two end games this
round um we have this one
and the fabiano end game which is
becoming less clear to me let's get over
to that because the fabiano
game i spied the board i don't know if
you saw me off camera maybe that's what
you called for because i'm like
i'm like wait how do you deal with the
pin on the e file not only is
wait bobby's neglecting that because
because apparently the bishop is
defended
he's going and getting another pawn
which i don't know that feels a little
scary here
somehow somehow you're starting to
you're starting to feel a little frisky
about some tactics
well you can take on e5 with the knight
because you're not actually hanging your
rook because
f3 falls the check so that would force
white to recapture
on e5 in some way or you can just play
rook a8 to start with i'm trying to
figure out the
nuances here like do i take on e5 do i
leave that for the time being play rook
a8 because behind the knight
on a7 is a pawn on a2 that i will gladly
capture
but if i can exploit the pin that you
first referenced i think that's where
your attention was danny
like somehow a knight takes e5 does feel
like
you know there should be something
tactically for and actually knight e5 if
you take back with the knight on e5
don't have rook c7 double attack on the
a7 knight and the e7 square you sure do
well you go knight b5 and go rook c5 and
double it down on your knight
well and i was looking for ways to
exploit the pin knight with the bishop
it's a very typical tactical ideas you
see him in king's indians all the time
but maybe there's something even more i
mean when we first came here by the way
we saw fabiano
kind of head in hand and that wasn't the
the focused
kind of two hands famous pictures you
see of him i think he was
i don't think he was thrilled with how
we approached this position
yeah it does feel like his advantage is
not nearly as great as it once was
um but it still
should be good for white but you can see
you can hear it like the question in my
voicing
the your voice gets high when you're
nervous i know that
all right let's head over to uh ikaru
and
dingley wren because speaking of getting
nervous is white getting nervous about
an exchange sack on b2 followed by some
dark square dominance
it's a very good question because if you
can do that and
go for the mating attack we mentioned
earlier on the h2 square that would be
great
i but do you have to go king h1 here i
feel like king h1 is the
the prudent move but hikaru is uh
even thought here dingley runs shuffling
more than you normally see i mean the
physical
manifestation is is kind of obvious that
he's a little nervous
um we almost i feel like we're
normally seeing a stoic you know dingley
wren one to make marcus aurelius proud
but not here okay he takes on d5
whoa yeah is your rook takes b2 moo
possible now
i no because i guess at the end of that
i just
if you bishop takes e5 i go rook takes
e5 and it's too many
uh yeah there's too many i mean
i don't even know what happens in the
end game i assume only white can win but
it might be a draw that's the thing if
icarl kind of wants to draw is this
is this a way to get it i don't know
but it feels like a car has the sort of
upper hand between the two players at
the moment so
just recapturing on d5 is what he did
and you still have this question for
ding like i would move my king
and this is one of those difficult
decisions danny where you want to play
king g1
in anticipation of queens getting off
the board and your king being close to
the center
but with queens and a dark square bishop
on the board putting yourself in a
diagonal
what rookie three dingley ren is trying
to come
over to the g file but that is a move
that
uh the the computers clearly didn't like
i i i have to love the opportunity to
give up the exchange
and you know not my brook so let's do it
is his idea after queen takes b2 bishop
takes e5 check you can go g3 or
something like
what you're giving me the queen for the
seventh rank i guess okay interesting
well i also have more material so if we
can trade queens in that manner
i mean this is this position is i mean
black has a pawn for the exchange
feels super dangerous for white right i
mean and what are the chances you get an
attack now that you took away your own
g3 square i mean
you have to love black there i do i
really like black's position i i almost
want to take with the pawn here and just
see what happens with a couple of pawns
and blow things open okay apparently
that's a horrible idea next time
thanks dan it's funny to be here you
could just come over here
okay good chalk good job well you know
that's uh
i i wanted to sack the exchange but
there you go i still think that it is
exactly the exchange can be good
for black but you just have to you know
kind of concretely figure it out you
don't want to
take it and then be like wait a second
where is my plan for the advantage
carl's shaking his head a little bit
robert's sorry to interrupt you but i
think we should head over to the
you young yi versus wesley so game
because uh we have
crazy liftoff there and knight is on g5
with check
sacrificing all in for the attack and
carlos shaking his head like
i bet that's that's not necessarily
because he thinks you bless these losses
he's looking at that like what is going
on in that game
well black decided not to develop the
queen side although that bishop has made
many moves this game
and the knight at one point was on a6
but black's queen side
stuck at home for the time being and
knight g5 check i mean
if you can you take that knight like it
scares me
to consider it you might have to let's
see what happens like i said
not my king so take back and bishop e6
okay and the point is if you have queen
h4 check i thought i have rook h6 but
the bar is
no you're probably right but there's a
better move to queen h4 i mean i'm just
watching the bar go up and down
yeah uh it's kind of fun it's like guess
the guess the bar
e2 danny ah queen e2 heads over to h5
and now you've got me
that's the key and just to show
everybody i mean okay a move like this
or even rook f8 pretty much fails to the
same point you check and play g6 and
bob's your uncle over here so um
okay wow okay so bishop e6
not a move that's possible i wonder if
even taking the knight is
is is really what you'd want to do this
is very very nerve-wracking for wesley
so obviously when you're
when you're down in development like
this you feel like you're down multiple
pieces so
i i really don't give much stock except
for the blunders we're making and when
the eval bar tells me i'm wrong i do
listen to it but but other than that i
don't really give the evaluation much
stock because i think this position
is very deep and and obviously black is
going to be favored
slightly right now everybody because of
the material but
this is a game where you see you could
see a horizon effect like somehow with a
little bit of time the engine really
starts to understand
that black is playing down three pieces
and alpha zero
alpha zero is hungry for an attack
it's hard to imagine that wesley came
into today's game wanting to
have this kind of position where yeah it
looks like all of white's pieces
are on their optimal squares and black
hasn't developed and
it feels like they're just even if the
engine somehow
finds a way out of this practically
speaking with you know just a couple
minutes on your clock
you're getting into a blitz game your
king is about to be blitzed as well
i just don't know how black survives
this
um let's keep these two guys on camera
on the board right here i'm going to
flash the board quickly to irena crush's
game with hoey fawn because i think we
might be moments away from our first
result
i think irena should be able to get a
draw over there
ephon goes in to take the pawn on b2
kind of uh at the risk of knowing
there's going to be a job wait we have a
first result and it's not this game back
this thing up quickly hikaru nakamura
and dingley ren have drawn their game i
think hikaru
i think hikaru knew he was better and so
offered the draw to flex a little bit on
the match position because he thinks
fabiano is going to win
but if he thinks he's better that
doesn't make any sense to make a draw
here i'm a little surprised because i
think i think
at this point hicaro maybe has played
the best game overall for team usa and
maybe he should have kept pushing
because
he's he's doing great okay but they have
drawn i think irina crush and
hoey fawn will draw which means it's
going to come down to these board two
and board three battles
um uh wesley so was on the clock oh no
he's not on the clock he took the knight
okay let's go back here
we could go to both games but i think we
got to go here before we go to fabiano's
game
and there must be oh whoa
that's what happens when you play a
tough position you can't defend all the
threats
and here there there's just you know i
mean what is the move
because you have what looks like a great
oh bishop d5 take away the g8 square and
get your queen h4 that looks
pretty good uh oh spaghettios
i mean bishop b5 you can't take my
bishop because your pawn is pinned to
your queen
and i'm threatening queen h4 check with
me now you're not exactly threatening it
because i still have your rook h6 idea
you pointed out earlier
i guess you do but it's even putting my
bishop on f7
feels yeah i mean i don't i do not want
to play black's position here don't get
me wrong
but but but i don't see an exact
knockout blow
just yet um oh bishop d5 has been played
it's on the board so
what does black even respond with here
yeah but and the crazy risk here is that
remember
china does win on a draw so i think
that's why we were surprised it felt
like hikaru nakamura was outplaying
dingley ren and maybe getting winning
chances as black
we'll see if it proves to be match
strategy correct um
i think i think ricardo thinks that you
know at least one of wesley and
fabiano can hold and the other one can
win
um i mean maybe icar's position was just
equal i mean yeah it may be
maybe it was just i'm gonna give him the
benefit
there's not really a doubt in my mind
that you know he's an exceptional player
there he wasn't
thinking that about the other board
chains he probably just acknowledged
that his game was about to peter out and
so it was just going to be a dead draw
well i think you know psychologically
getting a draw early maybe that helps
his teammates so hikaru getting a draw
kind of lets them know danny i love you
man but i i just can't see a way a draw
helps
team usa in any way shape or form
exactly because china has draws right
right yeah i'm trying to think about it
and you know it's going to be
nerve-wracking here down the stretch
uh let's go to fabiano caruana's game as
wesley tries to figure out how to deal
with bishop d5 fabiano is up a pawn
but i don't know that his winning
chances are better than they were
earlier
robert your thoughts look at that rook
on c2 it's so active
there and what it would love to do is go
after the f7 pawn because if you can
pile up pressure there and you can even
create an attack
uh then black could be in some trouble
and that's why
with black on the move right now and
actually only two minutes
wei is considering do i take on b2 or
does that allow some sort of uh rook
d7 or rook d8 and then rook to d7
because actually that could be a nice
little finesse
yeah and the other thing is is the time
pressure right so fabi's
bobby's bringing the practical noise if
you will in terms of
the potential of uh an attack we know
the rook and knight can be super
dangerous together with mating nets
and the fact that wei yi doesn't have a
ton of time on the clock here
and danny rook takes b2 should be meant
by rook d8 because it's a very important
point
you draw the king to f8 so then when you
go back to d7
you can take on f7 with check at the
right moment
ah dirty dog
classic hess
okay by the way we've seen this exact
line on the board
bobby working it that's how the rook and
knight do things
that's actually very very tough to deal
with i mean this is better in a lot of
ways if you're trying to get a win as
white than anything you might try to do
with an extra pawn on the queen side
because
at least from a practical perspective
the king under pressure this is such a
hard position to find accurate moves
maybe rookie two wasn't one
um you can take with check robert and
then play rook back to e7 because king
f8 fails tonight takes g6 check
actually no matter what you do you can
play knight takes g6 that's a great
point the great find there
oh and you're threatening knight takes
g6 because you've already gained a tempo
wow there aren't that many pawns
remaining though so that's the one
downside of if you trade rooks there
that if that black king quickly comes to
say g6 and attacks the g5 pawn
there's opportunity for black to uh
continue liquidating and then eventually
sacrifice the knight for remaining pawns
but
that's a far down the road approach that
wade doesn't really want to rely on
wow uh okay well if you're just joining
us yet again we are in the
super final sunday here on the first
ever feed hs.com online nations cup
we've got
uh almost 30 actually 30 000 of you
we've crossed 30 000 live viewers across
all platforms
we've got about 5 500 on youtube almost
25k here on twitch and if you're tuning
in from facebook periscope and mixer
you're not neglected we love you too um
danny uh we have to go to the fabio
another five minute car
yeah the west show game right yeah we
just yeah this is nuts and that
that's the one that's turning around in
the favor of team chyna very very
quickly this is getting scary and
it might put irina crush in a position
where she has to play for a win
and that doesn't i mean she's trying her
best and it looks like that position
is about level but look at this one the
bishop on e4 pinning the rook on g6
to the king on h7 um there are many
ideas for white including a quick queen
f7
piling up pressure on that pendrive king
to g2 with rook h1 checkmating ideas
to follow also
oh man this is yeah this is this is
going to be a victory team china is
going to score the first dub here
wesley is running up against the the
train that has been you young ye
all event uh the guy has been
unstoppable the only loss he had was to
wesley yesterday but
but you young yi uh said don't poke the
bear the bear bites back
and he is on the china pandas pro chess
league team so
uh you know the bear definitely does
poke back and what do you do now because
i would not play bishop take a g6 i
think it's an important lesson for
everybody watching
the rook isn't going anywhere it's
pinned so unless you have a forcing
checkmate and there's rook to d6 i think
that was a good move
unless you had a forcing checkmate there
was no need now king g2 threatening rook
h1
checkout
everything working well for white in
this position and black look at the
queen side that's what it all came down
to
i mean this is this is a super
instructive game a heartbreaker for team
usa but
uh you know we know this will probably
be getting some video game of the day
reviews
by those covering the event because this
is uh a godmother tour and guys at our
channel youtube.com
chess subscribe if you haven't this is
an instructive battle i mean you young
yi king g2 i expect we might even see a
resigns here wesley shakes his head
what a tough game and that means it's
all going to come down
fabiano has to convert no options and
irena crush
to save team usa would have to find a
way to beat
former women's world champion hoeifan
yeah i mean you know i'm just looking
from board to board here danny and this
one is a clear win
at this point for team china and wesley
shaking his head and
you know wesley shouldn't be faulted i
mean this is a tough position to be in
not
not just in terms of chess position but
as a team you need to score
more than your point you can't tie you
need to score more and so he needs to
hold with black of course that was what
he
intended to do but when wei is in this
form
he can beat anybody on the planet i
don't care if you're you're
magnus carlsen a car nakamura fight but
whoever you want to bring up
the way you think he's played all
tournament has been phenomenal yup
out of control chess honestly it has
been it's not just that he's been
winning games if you have not followed
this event as close as you should check
out the video replays of previous rounds
back up and watch our vods
yu young yi has won one brilliant game
after another and this one is no
exception
oh no that's it that's it irina crush
not able to get the victory i was spying
it
she has drawn her game to flash the
board
not a bad result you would think coming
in but because of the draw
previously between hikaru nakamura and
dingley wren we can officially say
that and that was the draw here that we
can officially say that if you young ye
wins this game
china wins the online nations cup
and look at this last move you know he
took the pawn in f3
and simply brought his king back to g2
and saying you know go ahead
take my rook on d1 if you really wanted
because you know
the material is not important it's king
safety and after bishop takes d1 i
simply play rook takes d1 back
threatening rook h1 checkmate your rook
on g6 is still pinned and
i mean white's just completely winning
well we knew they had a tough task
coming in having to beat chyna
but a tied match would not be good
enough despite the fact that fabiano
carwana
is going to win that game over there
with wei yi you just it doesn't seem
like a position that they can hold
um and uh ultimately
ultimately it won't be enough even with
a tight
tied 2-2 match but let's see you young
you finish this off yes he does wesley
so resigns
book it ladies and gentlemen china has
won the first ever feeding chess.com
online nations cup
and yu yangi with the fist pump there he
is
ecstatic about that game he played a
wonderful tournament and especially to
go off on that note there
getting his revenge he lost in the final
round two yeah wesley so
he said well payback hurts that's really
not the way they usually
use that expression but we're on a pg
friendly show well we've got to use that
we've got to show the game one more time
we'll get to the fobby game
very very quickly here but this was the
game that won the event so no game
replay could be more important
started with this amazing pawn sack on
e2 and then the initiative
the rooks grabbing the file the attack
on the king knight e5
check the piece sack wei yi i mean that
way you young yi
is is out of control and he wins a
brilliant game
to win the online nations cup wow i mean
you know before this match started i was
giving my mvp our daily question you
know who is the most valuable player
i think you young you just answered the
daily question although fabiano caruana
winning his game doesn't really change
my mind about the fact that he's going
seven half of the nine
across his games and is the reason in
many respects why team usa is here
um but i you know it's hard to blame any
player and i know
some people say well wesley wesley lost
so it's his fault or
you know hikara didn't play on it's vote
i mean you're playing team china
they are they're good they're good
they're amazing they're just amazing
and you know you have to give team
challenges
all the respect that they've earned from
their play in this event
i i don't think that you could have done
too much differently
for team usa of course not losing a game
but that's
advice to give everybody right if you
don't lose well you don't lose
duh but um you know yu yang yi like this
is just
he's on fire yep remind everybody
china had the best record throughout the
main event that we've been covering all
week here which is why they have draw
odds in this awesome super final
shout out to all 30 000 of you that are
with us here
to bring this sunday super event on this
very happy mother's day
to all mothers out there to a close but
uh fabiano despite
likely looking like he's playing a great
game like you said he's the only person
in the event or not in the event at
least playing in the super final here
who hasn't lost
um no no that's not true a couple other
people haven't lost but i guess
in regards to the amount of games he's
played right you gave that score earlier
in terms of uh the the the epic points
he's putting up
um and fobby's about to get another win
yeah i you know i'm still thinking about
this uh
overall and i see the chat going crazy
about not enjoying you know draws or bad
i mean it's essentially if you're
playing the last round of a tournament
and there's no super final
then um you know it's your
half point back or whatever you still
need to win so it's just like it was the
end of a tournament but
came down to one match everybody knew
what was at stake and how to
get the win and um yeah i mean
just i i just have to say credit again
to team china they've already won this
match by virtue of the fact that
a 2-2 tie is a victory for them and so
um danny i don't know what more can be
said nothing more to say right they've
been the best team throughout the event
usa
also had a fantastic event they they
added to their prize pool just by making
the super final
unfortunately by coming up short that
will be
there they will be taking home the
silver medal if you will uh wei yi does
just resign in fact because
after this very nice little instructive
maneuver i'll just show real quick as we
are here for the chess
the knight was trying to be pesky
against the white king but the king kind
of out
out footworks the knight here out
hustles it walking into some discovered
checks and once this knight gets to an
awkward square you go back to g3
because the knight is no longer able to
check on e2 if the rook had checked on
the third rank fabi would have blocked
it and now that the checks are gone
look for white's rook and knight to do
nasty things to the black king and the
pawn here so
that was a very nice little instructive
little footwork there from fabiano to
bring it to a close but it
but it is all team china let's bring up
our congratulatory graphic because they
are the the super power of chess these
days and many team events they they do
well in both men's and women's olympics
and in this event that is sort of the
first of its kind in terms of being kind
of an online chess olympics they do get
the job done
with a host of characters like you said
play for the china pandas in the pro
chess league those are a lot of familiar
faces which is why china
if you if you forgot and maybe haven't
followed the pro chess league as close
as you should have you can go to
protesting.com
they are once again in the final four so
that event has been delayed due to the
covet 19
uh pandemic obviously but that that is
team china that is the china pandas they
are awesome and they win
the feed hs.com online nations cup a
well-deserved victory for team china
gotta
tip your cap to them and you know they
had
some struggles of course and we just saw
in that final round fabiano carwana
took out wei yi but throughout the event
yu yang yi being the star for them and
dingley ren i think he's
kind of got under the radar just because
of how exceptionally
yu yang he has played but dingley wren
was a star on board one
for that team and he came through in a
big way um
you know in this game you know against
takara nakamura a level battle
just looking at his teammates needs but
dingley wren just like a car in nakamura
has been so great for team usa
dingley wren has been awesome for team
china well all these players have been
good for all of us the fans win when it
comes to all the online events like this
and so many
great chess websites holding so many
great events this has been an awesome
one we're going to be back here in just
a moment
with interviews final thoughts breaking
down game reviews and also a very very
big announcement about upcoming
online chess events here on chess.com so
don't go anywhere when we return
we will be uh giving some big interviews
some big announcements and
wrapping up here the feed hs.com online
nations cup
[Music]
so
and we are now back here with the fide
chess.com online nations cup with the
winners of the event
team china first of all to all of you
congratulations
thank you thank you uh ifon i'd like to
start with you great great day great to
see you
i feel like the last time we were here
you were joining us as a commentator
yeah exactly i think it was the thing
for a cup okay somewhere
and and now you're here once again as a
player i think i think um it's been a
big story line for all of us following
the event
to see you sort of come come out of
retirement right uh during this uni
the unique times of covet 19 but also of
course the
uh this event giving the opportunity how
exciting it has has it been for you to
play
in an elite chess event for the first
time in in a while
uh wow so i mean quite i'm more excited
about that
actually we're here that uh
that chess.com and fed are actually
organizing this event
for top players who are representing
their countries or their regions
whatever because under this global
climate actually it is very important
that
we are trying to bring out something
together
that make chess somehow still uh on the
air you know
so this is i guess one of the privilege
for chess as we can do
a lot of different events online
therefore i thought that i'm very
glad to be part of the team china and
participate in this event
and for me yeah of course it's always
good you know come back to the
chessboard and playing some games
though i would say that this event that
we're playing online with this
very special format that you know have a
team with the
uh mr gender so this is something really
different but very interesting and also
i'm very happy that our team did a great
performance
thank you no good robert that was very
well said and well i think we have to
talk to
you yankee because you were kind of the
all-star for team chat throughout i mean
everyone did
well as a team but you seem to be on
fire what was going on like
were you just in the in the right
mindset for this event how did you
prepare
yeah yes thank you and today i just
play my game because yesterday i
followed my team
game i lost the game
i think my opponent very strong today i
just
want to play with the game yeah
yeah it makes sense uh
i'm gonna ask a question to you uh
dingley wren you you've also
you also had a great event um right
right there along with along with you
holding down board one uh how how tough
was it for you
to uh to be holding down board one and
for all the opponents you had here and
how did you feel about your overall
performance there
for today yeah
today and throughout the event yeah of
course today is the most important day
in this tournament and i prepared a lot
but
it turns out to be uh
not so good for me since i totally
misplayed after the middle game and i
was
worse and he surprised me by andrew
offer that i was
not considered and i think my position
is already slightly worse
i was actually just going to ask you
that were you were you relieved when the
draw offer came and it sounds like you
were
kingly right yeah good sorry i was
surprised
so i just accepted this offer
uh immediately
and free free wei did you feel relieved
when you saw that hecarim and and
uh ding dong drew their games was that a
relief for you because your position was
pretty tough at that point
well uh in the ending i think uh
mikey and dinglinskin those are very
dangerous then i saw
he got a jaw and then i think maybe
young he had some chance to win
so yes i had a
better performance but my teammates
played very well i i wanted to ask a
question here to
to to help us round this out a team
china is known
as not just the global superpower
obviously that the chinese team is
is performing amazing and not just
individually but in so many team events
so congratulations to all of you and and
and to the country and i wanted to ask
individually i'll start with you if on
uh is there something about team events
that makes that makes it even more
special uh for
for the team china performing so well in
olympia's and performing so well in
events like this
do you do you guys prepare well as a
team is or is it just something about
the dynamic of it that you feel brings
out the best chess
starting with you if on when china plays
in team events
uh well i thought that it cannot be
judged by a single factor it actually
works out together so firstly i guess
we're
having the uh very good team spirit that
means that
the uh the general atmosphere is very
harmony and
people are tend to have like you know
sometimes discussing together
just like as teammates but also as
friends i guess that is very important
though you know everyone can perform
very good individually but when you're
applying team competition sometimes
you know um you need to be in that form
and you need to act well to consider you
are part of the team so i guess that
in this sense actually in china doing
very well and
actually we also have this long
tradition as if we recall back to the
few decades ago
that um you know many grandmasters from
china
the earlier generation did a great job
they won
first woman's team won the olympiad and
then also our guys won olympia
back to 2014 and even were team
champions before so all of this actually
you know brought
bro to our generation and we kind of
just mm-hmm
that's right i got that yeah
you young yi how do you feel about about
team events it it certainly brought out
some good chess for you right
[Music]
because we are a team yeah i just um
every game uh certainly
yeah i just analyzed
[Music]
i don't want to put you on the on the
spot if i'm uh having having trouble
with the
translation no word no worries weigh
yeah your thoughts on playing in a team
event
how important is you
kenya i think
i always always
had that for amazing team evans
this is maybe ever again i played
in some pressure
and then i think i played very bad
but i was very lucky because
i i have a very very strong teammates
that's how i feel most the time i feel
very lucky because i have a strong
teammate
um but uh dingley ren i guess we'll
we'll go finish the circle your thoughts
on how you how you play in team events
versus individual events
yes i feel i i
i'm more motivated i also have more
pleasure
by playing team events very strange
since today i feel very nervous before
the game
fully played against magnus in
the magnus invitational i think today
maybe
i was more nervous and i prepared
more time today
since uh not my own game
if i lost or very very badly they will
cause the match it's more
important than individual results
got it well you didn't lose you came
through there
obviously team chyna almost uh i mean
almost didn't lose a single match all
event besides besides the one yesterday
so
uh congratulations again to all of you
we could keep you here for a while but i
don't think we have too many more
follow-up questions and we'll let you go
celebrate the team victory so
congratulations to all of you again
congratulations bye everybody yes thank
you
position for her i wanted it so bad and
he did it
now take the a rope
and that video being an outro to our
interview with team china but not by
mistake
as a big announcement we have here is
that with more details to come
this year we are increasing the speed
chess championship
prize fund from what has historically
been 50 000
for the last several years to 250 000
and making it an annual season event
with a completely
redesigned qualification system robert
we uh
the the main event itself is going to be
doubled from
what was a 16 player knockout bracket
to now being a 16 player knockout
bracket for a hundred thousand dollars
uh
instead of fifty thousand and we're very
excited about this we've been putting a
lot of thought into how to
unify and bring so many of the events
we're doing together
and uh we are making a huge step that
starts in june
to launch a speed chess championship
grand prix series that ultimately leads
to a 100 000
knockout bracket so i know the speeches
championship is your favorite event
in the world and so how pumped are you
about the stakes getting a little bit
higher here
i'm very excited i mean i love the
speeches championship you know it's
fast-paced
it's many of the best players in the
world and so and what more could you ask
for so i'm looking forward to it
it's great to have chess especially
online chess in a time like this and
with uh bigger prizes it's bigger stakes
i think everybody is going to be
really motivated to do their best yeah
well we're super pumped about it it's
the first time we've broken the news
more details will come
we're going to take a very short break
and when we come back we're going to
review some more games
highlight for you what was the last
round here the super final
of the feedahs.com online nations comp
we will talk a little bit more about
what the new format of the speedchest
championship will be
all the the prizes increase and where
that's going and what the opportunities
are for title players to qualify for
that so
more breakdown of what was team china's
victory here
in the super final and uh much more
thoughts in just a couple minutes
[Music]
so
and we thank everyone who is still with
us here the super final of the feed
hs.com online nations cup wraps up with
a
a tied match that ultimately delivers
china the match victory
because of their draw odds that they
earned throughout the event but
one guy who ensured that it was going to
be a tied match with a victory over wei
yi
is fabio karwana and he joins us now
fabi thanks for being here
hey danny have you wish your mother
happy mother's day yet
yeah i i have i did this morning when i
woke up okay i didn't want robert to be
worried about it that was awesome
you know he he wished his mother happy
mother's day he won his game what more
could you ask for
what can you ask for her son right well
um bobby take us through this game
you've been so awesome joining us and
giving us the breakdown
um were you surprised to see the
scandinavian first of all hashtag teams
candy
yeah this was a surprise i i mean i i
expected either
a night or maybe something some sort of
rui lopez i mean he he's always been a
night of player
right and that's he was kind of mixing
up a bit in this event and playing
he played the open spanish against
karjakin
but the scandinavian i really didn't
expect because it's it's not
at all within his repertoire or even
like the types of positions that he
normally goes for um so
do you think he did it as a nod to john
bartholomew in his upcoming i am not gm
speechless championship match 100
we're going to get to that and give you
let give you a chance to make
predictions
uh about the upcoming john bartholomew
versus greg shahadi
i'm not a gm but okay we had a
scandinavian uh
i'm clicking through the game i think
you can see it let us know if you have
any thoughts about the line you chose
or you know any more surprises at some
point it seemed like it turned around
and he was using
time on the clock so maybe he wasn't
expecting the variation that you played
here
i i don't think that he was really very
well prepared for this line
i mean i just i don't know anything
about queen d8 i was just
making moves which seem kind of natural
logical oh right
i don't i don't think that any of my
moves could be really criticized at the
start because
i mean obviously if i develop in this
way it can't be bad right i don't know
if
something more critical for white than
that maybe there's something which is
more
uh which is more dangerous for black
than this but this looked pretty good
and i was very surprised he played b6 i
thought his idea with this was
i don't know how to play like e6 97 some
sort of
development like that where black is
certainly a bit worse but um
it's not disaster and it's important
that knight b5 he has an id8 so he
he doesn't lose a pawn on c7 right
he did lose his pawn on c7 didn't he
yeah well he played b6 as you said
and then we i mean obviously we weren't
sure he would go for the e6 line but
robert in live fashion kind of predicted
that black struggles because
uh the bishop coming here there's
obviously worries with b4 maybe i mean
you know
the knight's a little tender but there's
tactics here and so when he played e6
and
voluntarily goes for the the pawn down
end game
what were your thoughts at this point i
was expecting e6 i didn't see a single
move
besides that because bishop b7 b4 uh
doesn't work out for him
either after knight h5 i have like
bishop d2
um or
[Music]
yeah i can't see the board anymore no i
was gonna say it looks pretty good right
so well knight d5 knight d5 and uh
he he gets to my work on a1 like queen
d5 ba-5
right the two is along with uh the
attack that i'll have
because his his king side now no longer
has a defender
i think this is more or less completely
gone for black
uh basically i just lost so i expected
him to go for the end game because i
didn't see any other options
well fabi when you got to this end game
you did win a pawn
but did you feel like there was this
burden on you it's a team event that you
needed to win just for your team to have
a chance
i i think it was still too early to say
none of the other games had really been
um like it wasn't clear what was going
to happen they were they
the contours of the game weren't really
set yet
so i i didn't know if i had to but my
general feeling before the match was
that
uh our chances were rather limited i
mean
um we are probably slight underdogs
against a team like china
and they have drawds and um
you can't really expect a player to win
with black i think it's
it can happen but it's not really
something that you should
you should calculate beforehand um and i
thought that
uh i mean irene of course has a chance
to win but generally speaking of drawn
that board would be
a fine result right so so it's you're
sort of left with my
with my board as like the as the
remaining white game
with some chances to to win um and
that was like i was very happy in the
middle of the match because i thought i
have good winning chances
uh i thought that he car's position was
unclear but it didn't look bad for him
wesley's position looked i i wasn't
really sure i mean once tonight was on
b8 i thought
uh he really has no development but i
also kind of
trusted in his ability to wriggle out of
it um right
and irene's position looked completely
sterile i i felt like that was
more or less immediately going to be a
draw um
which i think was was fine for our team
um so it takes us back to you because
you had this position
um you know here and you know what was
it like like you
when you were going through this game
did you feel like your chances were very
high to win this game or did you feel
like black had good chances to hold
uh the half point i thought i should be
objectively close to winning
but i just wanted to point out a funny
moment because i played g4
and yeah
after bishop of five i mean this is not
necessary but
uh but bishop c2 is is sort of a
critical move
i thought and then i play rookie one so
the bishop doesn't have many squares to
go to
it has to go to e4 and here at first i
thought i would play g5
fish f3 gf bishop b2
fg and i thought this was a clever way
to win but then i saw rookie ada
and he actually defends his bishop and
it's it still stays alive
but instead of g5 then i saw my d2 and
it all kind of fell together
uh instead of g5 yeah he has like knight
d4 here but i i felt like either bishop
a6 or g5 would work out for me there
right maybe g5 was even cleaner
so knight d2 was important to see i
think and
and after bishop b6 i felt okay uh
in the game oh no i i blundered g5 rook
c3
yeah no vision basics was winning
okay so he played no that's a that's a
good point and we um
we're kind of bouncing around at this
point like fashion we had almost kind of
given a lot of attention to start saw
you won the pawn and said well
fob he's probably going to be in control
of that one so you know looking at the
other games we
we missed some of those critical tactics
so that's that's nice for the viewers to
see
but okay the game went on and and we
came back to it
with full attention right around here
when you played knight b5 and we were
we were looking at this with a little
bit of nervousness from the perspective
that
looked like it had gotten a little shaky
but were you were you confident
throughout that
you could win this second pawn and even
if black wins some material back you
should have winning chances
well i i i felt like i had misplaced it
and the thing is i had planned id six
and seven night a seven when i got here
okay but what made you go against that
yeah take rook takes i mean he doesn't
have to take what i think he should
and knight g4 and this tactic is
and f6 at first i thought this should be
a very good endgame but
like he gets counter played with rook c4
i mean i get my rook to the seventh it
looks very good but i'm not really
establishing my establishing establish
my night on e4 in time um
and it started to feel a bit unclear so
i went for knight a7 based on
um some brief calculations like rook c5
bishop six team joining
um rookie two rook d a bishop of fate
and now knight c8 i think is a good move
and he has to play rook c7 but then i
thought many moves should win like
knight g5 or
right or probably other things as well
because he's he he's kind of internally
pinned and knight h7 is a threat
all sorts of things okay um but there
might be something even better than that
you
um okay you sorry you first saw the game
continuation you know
when you took an a7 and i mean what was
happening here was looking like you know
some pieces are getting traded so do you
have any fear
i mean fear is a strong way of putting
it but did you have any concern that
as pieces get traded that maybe his
chances to draw increase or you still
felt very confident
that you were you know on the path to
scoring the full point
now at this point i felt like it should
be objectively a draw
and i thought that he should play f6 at
one moment or another either
like right now either now or after
bishop 595 i wasn't sure which is
uh which is better um i mean of course
i'm playing for two results that there's
really no risk for me
right coming but
if he plays f6 now you're saying you
just don't quite have
yeah well i have d8 here
um fv5 rook uh e8 king of seven now
let's say i throw a check in on e7
yeah i don't know if it's yeah let's say
king of f8 and i work c7
and i'm still better but objectively
it's probably
probably not going to be winning um
right when he's low on time i think
they're still
yeah the time pressure combined with
ideas maybe like that so it's still hard
for black but okay so you thought you
might get a position like this
or i was expecting him to take on e5
first and then f6
and then um i guess i'll take knight
takes and
uh and he wrote d6 so this one actually
i thought that
i this one i wasn't really worried about
okay he might pick up f2 but
my pawns are much faster i have the two
connected passes
so like v6 knight of two a4 uh
i don't really think i'm worried about
his pawns you're just pushing and forget
this guy
you just run over here with the king
interesting yeah
i thought that my winning chances should
be pretty
high here right wow
okay but i was really happy when he took
on b2 because then i thought it should
just be a win
so he took on b2 and yeah we were here
too and we uh
highlighted this very nice rook d8
maneuver where you bring the king to fa
with check and at this point it seems
like
the king side is just way too weak and
unfortunately at this point probably the
the actual you know memo was setting in
though right because this i think it was
about this exact position here where you
young yi finishes off yet another
uh brilliant victory right in defeating
wesley so so
um your thoughts i wanted to point out
because he played this very clever move
rookie one
okay um i mean rookie two i think was a
blunder
when he played rookie two people just
missed that i can play rookie seven
because right
move but then he played the very clever
rookie one
um and now king g2 he has knight g7
knight g6 ninety six
and uh coming wow
and i'm losing a piece or the exchange
or something which is not what i want
so so that's why i had to click so
actually let me ask you
a question because it's very easy to
play king to g2 after rookie one check
just you know
it's the obvious move how did you like
keep your composure here to realize that
black actually still has some chances
because to a player as strong as you and
even to my eye it just seems like white
is winning at this point
so how do you take that pause and not
rush the decision
well rookie one is a completely
nonsensical move if there's not a trick
um because otherwise you just don't take
the a2 point like if i play king g2 i
basically pick up his g
pawn without even losing a2 right
but it makes no sense unless there's a
trick and right and logically the trick
should be after the most logical move
king g2
uh because h2 is a bit less what do you
want to do
i mean it leaves f2 hanging which is
you'd rather keep it protected
right so and since black's options are
so limited it kind of came very quickly
that
that his trick was knight g796
it's really interesting i mean just to
hear your thought process and we still
have
almost 25 000 actually we do roughly 25
000 of you with us still so thanks for
tuning in here the results are in if you
if you didn't get
the the memo china wins but a huge
victory by fabinho karwana
and with that trick that he just showed
us really interesting insight but
it brings us to a question fabi yuyong
yi gets the job done for team china as
he did
pretty much throughout the event but you
also were on the
short list of a lot of people's
candidates for our daily question which
is
who's the mvp of the event right if we
had a season and we were asking an
all-star
question who would get your mvp for the
for the event
could get my mvp yeah i would get my mvp
okay great that's what i wanted to hear
there you go and by the way you were
you were robert's pick as well i mean
it's it makes a lot of sense
you have it you didn't lose out the
entire event you came up with some huge
victories and
ultimately you dominated china's board
too right so you kind of did your job
against china
against wang hao and wei yi so um let's
take a second
and just you know step back here and ask
your thoughts on the overall event i
mean what did you think
of the first ever online nations cup the
format
the experience and go ahead and speak
your mind if you don't mind tell us tell
us what you thought about the event and
your overall performance with team usa
uh i mean i enjoyed playing it
enormously
i think the final was a bit
anticlimactic
um i mean i i know it kind of sounds
like
as the losing team in the match it
sounds a bit like an excuse but
um but it would be nice to see a tie
break or something some sort of
continuation of the match or
or i mean like from my point of view i
just played one game today
which feels like a very um
like a bit of a premature finish
yeah well i would agree with you uh fabi
but also
i mean you know in that question like
what advantage should the team that
finishes in first place
throughout those 10 rounds get in a
final like this
um it's difficult to come up with a
format
on the spot i i think that for sure uh
the winning team should get an advantage
i mean they completely outperformed um
every other team in the uh in the group
stage
uh and i i think they they were the
deserted winners i mean they
just because they tied this one match
doesn't mean that they didn't
overall dominate the tournament right uh
but it was more in the interest of just
making it more of a
um you know down to the wire sort of
finish rather than
just one match right and i'm not sure
exactly
exactly how that could be achieved but
i'm sure there's there's some way to
make it
um you know like a grander final and
said
right well i mean obviously it's uh it's
been an interesting experience and for
sure with the uh
the folks working hard with the
formatted feed a and here
here within within our site i can say i
mean it'll be it'll be great to be able
to try to build on this and continue to
make
great online events um speaking of great
online events we understand you've
become a bit of a
of a closet fan of one particular event
you wanna you wanna give us your
breakdown of what you see in the final
four here given given that you've been
following the i'm not a gm speech yes
championship so let's talk about it
yeah i've been following it closely i've
watched all the matches
um did you watch mine please tell me you
didn't watch mine
it was i watched your match uh against
uh against
teddy i was i thought that was like the
most spectacular match of the event so
far really oh wow well thank you
i mean we did go to overtime i guess
yeah it was i think the closest
and um and there was like that one
twist at the end right when everyone
thought you were dead
and then the rook on uh was it b7 or c7
gets hung oh yeah that's right he hung
his rook
oh man yeah well you did you really did
follow it wow i gotta
um up my game next time now that i know
you're watching but you will be watching
when bartholomew and jihadi throw down
and then
your boy teddy over there against selena
your thoughts on what we're gonna see in
these final two matches real quick
um i think that john should be
should be a pretty big favorite um i
actually expected
uh carissa to beat greg uh
but it didn't didn't quite happen uh and
john i expect to be a favorite but
i'm i'm hoping for a close match uh
and yeah i'm yeah i support teddy i've
known him for
i don't even know how long i mean since
we were kids we were playing chess
together
so so i'm supporting him to get to the
final yeah and
bobby be honest are you watching because
you like the tournament or you just want
me you know to see me and then i have to
respond to your messages when you hit me
up about the tournament
yeah i'm just watching for you for your
commentary
well bobby uh thanks so much for joining
us man and we're all looking forward to
the final four there in the uh
i'm not a gm sec and now people know
you'll be watching but um
dude you had it you had a great event uh
definitely make a case for the mvp
overall and uh congratulations to team
usa even though it came up a little
short and we we hope to have you again
in events in the future
yeah thank you it's my pleasure thanks
robbie
yes we got some awesome felt like very
personal coaching from fabiano carwana
throughout the event
we remind everybody you can get personal
coaching now on android
we're very excited about this if you
haven't tried this app i cannot
recommend it enough and i know that's
our job
but um not kidding it is very very
insightful and surprisingly instructive
for an artificially intelligent
overlord who just looks like your very
generous uncle who took you to that one
movie that
you'll never forget dr wolf um
fabiano has been great i mean this
analysis is great i'm like on the edge
of my seat trying to follow and
it's awesome and him and hicaro both
helped lead team usa with the most
games they played ultimately couldn't
quite get the gold but um
it was it was awesome let's let's bring
up the results here and in full view so
everyone can
remind themselves of what just happened
here in the super final nakamura drew
dingley wren
um a bit of a surprising finish that i
think just left a lot of fans hanging
right not just because cecaro tends to
have more fans than anybody else
watching
but i think they wanted him to keep
pushing um and and
ultimately maybe coming in a draw
wouldn't have been a bad result as black
against dingley ren i think
i think it felt like uh there might have
been a chance for more
well dangler himself said he was
surprised right so we heard it from
one of the players mouse themselves and
i'm not trying to
make any sort of grander statement but
it did come as a surprise just because
it felt like there was more life in the
position
right even if it ultimately will be a
draw like playing it out could be useful
and uh you know it just was maybe not
hikaru's game to win because he he was
pressing he was very
i was impressed with his play the black
side but i also would be remiss not to
mention
the other two players we focused way too
much in my opinion on just fabiano and
ikaru they would not be
in the super final if not for wesley so
he beat yu yang yi
in that game to win them the match and i
should point out that irina crush
despite being heavily outraged on her
board drew joo
in june yesterday and drew hoeyfun today
so irina deserves major props for
stepping up
in a very difficult spot where she's the
underdog she's the point
in the match where you're like wait a
second if we want a victory for team
china like shouldn't we
aim for board four where we're outraging
our opponent by a couple hundred points
so both wesley and arena you know they
performed admirably although today of
course you know
the highlight game it's a really a
fantastic finish they're a photo finish
by yu yang yi both those players deserve
props and i don't want to leave them out
of the conversation
yeah absolutely and uh the the game as
you said
um between uh between you young and
wesley so i'm gonna bring it up one more
time here as uh
as it was yet again just
i mean i feel like i want to call it
it's you it's you young yee's brand of
chess you know he said in the interview
and and for those of you that have been
here throughout that
that uh this whole show it was a little
tough at times obviously there were some
things being lost in translation and we
apologize for that but but
you young yi it was just awesome to join
us robert and
and gave his thoughts one of the things
he did say was that yesterday he kind of
felt like he played the team game which
was i translated a little bit of not to
lose
today this was not a game that he played
not to lose i mean this game was awesome
right
it was it was one that you know it's
kind of seared into your memory because
it was a blistering attack
towards the end of it but you're out of
the opening we got this feeling
at least is i was saying that you know
you've got to split pawns for black
and then black returned the favor and
split white's pawns
but it just felt like the advantage sat
with um
on the white side because you know his
bishop on g2 that's the piece i pointed
out and ultimately that bishop on g2
became the hero you know it landed on e4
at the end with some pins
but that bishop one g2 is just such a
strong minor piece in the position
and that queen c2 move also you you know
you noted that
wesley so start taking time in response
to queen c2 it's like just not giving
black an easy move a bishop e6 with a
tempo rook to b8 with the tempo when
that queen was on b3 so queen to c2
dropping it back
gives white more flexibility and i think
that move in particular is one that's
praiseworthy
yeah i i agree it's the move that gave
wesley pause took away the f5 square you
highlighted that probably
he just didn't want bishop e6 maybe just
because he doesn't want to lose the
bishop pair right and and
in hindsight maybe this would have been
welcomed rather than getting checkmated
in like a blistering attack right
but this is certainly one where you
would literally be handing yu yonggi a
two result game for
for forever more with uh with the bishop
here so
understandably so wesley didn't want
that but as we highlighted in real time
that meant that black was going to have
some struggles there's where do you put
pieces if you can't develop the bishop
to e6 because the bishop pair
you didn't want to go to f i mean you
can't go to f5 anymore
you don't want to go to g4 because what
are you going to do is give up the
bishop pair this way on a move like
queen e4
so black was stuck and the reason we're
highlighting everybody is because this
is where the wheels started to come off
now that we have our full 2020 hindsight
view right
queen to c7 was played after a long
think here comes queen e4
the light scores are opened up and
really it started to go wrong when you
saw this move here
this was the underdeveloping move that
probably wesley really wishes he could
have back this move knight to b8
yeah sorry i'm going to take a drink of
water i've been talking for hours keep
going go for it yeah
so so black is underdeveloped
undeveloping
right now the rook comes to d1 bishop a6
is met by queen e6 which was was really
that was the moment you really start to
feel yu young yi feeling it because
he doesn't care what the computers think
he understands the development
initiative
is is going to be the thing that wins
this game and i think
i think to our credit even though we we
said hey you know wesley was going to
take the pawn we were like you know this
position
forget what the computers were saying uh
we knew that this position was very very
dangerous for black because the extra
pawn is not going to tell the story for
a very long time
and white was just going to be bringing
all kinds of pressure
into the into the center here and so um
it was a a kind of thematic sacrifice
here because you look at the queen on c4
the king doesn't have to escape to g8
and so when you open up the h file
you look at how that diagonal is covered
and so if i can get a rook to h1
then your king is going to be in
checkmate so the engine's i mean i'm
looking at the bar
i love that the engine is so wrong about
this position it makes me so happy
well it could just be a depth issue
right where it doesn't see you know the
full extent but it also probably means
that black had a defense
available to him and after hg5 hg5
you know he played his work to g6 and
you see the evaluation go back up
maybe this we saw bishop e6 excuse me
didn't work so maybe bishop a6
that way there's no queen e2 uh retreat
and queen h4 is still met by rook h6 uh
after
uh this variation so that rook h6
maneuver is very helpful
yeah it's still very difficult for black
to even play
even there right you're still down
material and you would still take white
i think in terms of the the pressure and
the attack that
that you're getting because even on
bishop a6 okay we know the game in the
the move in the game was bad but even on
bishop a6 you know if the queen goes
anywhere
else the point is you still can't
develop right i don't know where that is
if not h4 because of rook h6
like even queen b3 you just you just
keep the position
and this is just such a nightmare for
black to have to defend this kind of
attack
well there's one uh important
distinction because look at the game
continuation for a second
so if we go back and see what happened
in the game look at the move that was
played
bishop d5 is not possible if the queen
is not on c4
pinning the c6 that's a really that
might have been the key defensive moment
wesley had maybe
one opportunity here to not get blown
off the board
and it was maybe to find a move like
bishop a6 to stop this bishop to d5 idea
again that's the big difference is
there's no
there's no way to take advantage of the
pin although apparently
rook g6 clearly is not the move because
i mean we see the uh you can come in
here i guess that's it
and now there's all kinds of problems f5
is falling that's i guess that's the
problem with the bishop
not being on c8 yeah you can also just
go bishop f3 kg to rook h1 the ideas are
not going to change in terms of
checkmating attacks but um you know just
the point is that
it's such a tough position for black to
defend here
and it was just going it goes to show
that yu yang yi's
um decision making paid off he went not
all in
but he went in a way that is a
calculated risk he gives up a knight
but black's king will never find any
sort of shelter and as we saw in the
game i mean it was just a
knockout blow yeah he took this pawn
walked into the check and backed up
which was a fun way to end the game
wesley resigns in lieu of rook h1 and
the fact that it's unstoppable
not even winning back a ton of material
but just just mating
um you know and like i said the not only
this was the game of the round for china
but the player of their event in many
ways you young e as
as we say we could give credit to every
board and we should and
again there's there's no way to not say
that that's why these teams are super
teams
but um but he he definitely rose to the
occasion
and like he said he played his game he
played his brand of chess
you know in in the interview and he told
us that he played his game today and it
paid off so
uh let's bring up the full lineup and
give credit to all the players who
played for team china
remember that wong hao and juwon jun
it's not every day
you can let a current competitor in the
feed a candidates
in wong hao sit out and the reigning
women's world champion and zhu when june
sit out
but your team is still that strong
yes there's nothing else say that team
is
super strong they were the deserved
champions they
as fabiano caron himself said they just
dominated the event from start to finish
and in the end they just got the two
points they needed to defeat team usa in
the super final
yeah no it's it's uh
it was just amazing breath taken away
and this has been a very long event an
exciting one but team chyna the deserved
winner
and uh can't wait to look forward at the
chance to
do another event like this but right now
the big announcement that we also made
that we're looking forward to
and the one that we still have more than
25 000 of you with us
to take note of big announcement today
is that we are increasing
our prize fund in the speeches
championship to 250 000
in total prizes throughout the cycle and
the main event itself is being doubled
from 50 000 to 100 000 just for the
single
16 player bracket now i'll give a little
bit of high level thoughts on this
because uh people may want to know what
does that mean right well starting in
june
we are going to have a massive increase
in the title tuesday prizes along with a
format shift robert
that we've already kind of foreshadowed
was coming right something that's going
to extend the rounds a little bit but
then put the top players into a bracket
where they join us on camera they're not
only required to screen share and have
video for security but also because the
prizes are so increased
a good reason to do that but also for
entertainment we'll get to see the best
players duking it out
the qualifier throughout that will also
lead to a different type of a point
system that's going to put people into
the seated bracket so
tons of details to come we're super
excited but um
it's uh it's going to lead to uh i think
a lot of interest as we build toward an
annual
an annual event and one of the one of
the events that everyone looks forward
to every year is the main scc
for sure and from team china i mean
dingley wren will be happy to hear that
i'm sure and
uh maybe yu yang yi's saying that hey i
want to get involved with that my
speed chest my rapid chess abilities are
clearly up there with the best of them
in the world so
uh the speech championship in general is
such a great event and of course
also coming up is the european online
chess championship
so for those of you who are from europe
that would not be us you're able to play
and compete in this event and that's
actually
less than a week away i don't even
realize how soon it is yeah no it's
going to be amazing it's uh something
that
they're already getting more entries for
that than than
they thought i think it's it's really
going well as far as interest and
participation
and it'll be a huge team effort by
everyone at ecuanchest.com to
to observe everything closely make sure
everything is fair which we will
been talking a lot about that for those
who always ask you can see
our breakdowns of what we do over on our
youtube channel replay some of the vods
in terms of our approach to fair play
um and there's also been a lot of hype
surrounding the title tuesday just as
is during the coven 19 kind of breakout
bringing more events online as
as every online chess server is right
now and the people that win are the
people watching these shows the fans win
it's been uh a ton a huge effort i would
say collectively by the global chess
community and
shout out to all the sites doing that
leaches chess24
chess.com everyone's doing their part to
bring
great chess and entertainment to the
fans and we hope everyone's appreciating
that but guess what
that prize fund is going up it's not
going to be sixteen hundred dollars in
june
i'm not going to say exactly what it is
yet uh but uh
the it's only getting only getting more
as the title tuesdays
joins joins the greater speech chess
championship grand prix we're pretty
pumped
and i'm going to leave it at that
besides to say how pumped are you that
the next time you'll be on camera i
think robert
is for the i'm not a gm scc with downing
i'm not allowed to commentate on that
because i'm not good enough
i'm so pumped because i don't have to
wear a blazer anymore i can dress
down i can be casual i'm going to have
donaldsky
with me for the coverage and it's just
such a fun event the players
are so just happy to be there they're
doing a little bit of trash talking
the events have a still high level so
donnie and i will have the coverage may
14th
10am pacific time as well as may 16th at
4 p.m pacific time
for the final four of that event but
danny it's been so fun covering this
event with you it's been a while since
we've commentated together and we were
doing the candidates
working with donya commenting on my bad
chess instead of my bad jokes
yeah i mean i was just trying to give
you a compliment so you didn't have to
be self-deprecating to ruin my
compliment because now
i feel like i have to insult you some
more and then you'll give yourself a
compliment and then we'll go in this
cycle but
on a serious note it's been really fun
doing this commentary with you danny and
everybody's been tuning in
uh thank you so much for your support
whether you're a supporter of an
individual team of chess as a whole it's
meant a lot
to the game of chess and to me
personally so thank you so much as
always for tuning in and
i mean danny i don't know if you want to
compliment me in return but you don't
have to
so i'll leave the floor to you of course
i'm working with the greatest
commentator
in the world okay that's grandmaster
robert hess and you know i you know i
actually believe that you are the man
thank you so much for holding it down
right now you've been doing more
commentary for our events than anybody
and uh it's always a pleasure we've had
a great time the team here i mean i
think this has been one of the best
events we've ever been able
to hold the production and the effort
there so shout out to my producer he's
right over there
and everyone that makes it it's not even
a one-man crew we do so much with all
the different production the assets the
graphics the sheets everything that goes
into it
it takes a whole team so thank you so
much to simon to uh the man who puts all
of our events together and organizes the
bleep out of things no one works harder
than nick barton here at chess.com and
he has done a fantastic job
getting everything together with fide of
course our partners at fide
uh the the phoenix president or connie
divorcovic it starts with him at the top
and everybody there who brought this
event together brought this event to us
and and we decided to throw it down
uh and uh it's it's been awesome again
shout out to our mods the people who
make
everything here a great community uh we
know that there's a lot a lot of things
that could
help chess chats and straight things go
off off
off different paths and we appreciate
everyone focusing and on the positive
and being here to support the game so
without that without any further ado
again one more time congratulations to
team china and team usa for making the
final in team china
for taking the gold here so for
chess.com and the first ever feed a
online nations cup we bid you adieu we
sign off and we will see you for future
events
happy mother's day to all the moms
[Music]
foreign